foreign
we're going to start again we're going
to start off with um
as we recessed our
discussion yesterday concerning
retirement bills a representative
Maguire I think has a fairly good idea
he'd like to go over the retirement
bills he's got some charts up here he's
going to create
as far as what they do and what he
understands them to do so representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman so
I read House Bill 436 in detail last
night I also have been I have a bill
that's related to the retirement system
so I've been trying to understand it
over time and it seems to me that it's
likely that the other members of the
committee don't understand
the same items in as much detail as I do
and so I think we should before we make
any decisions right we should understand
very clearly what's going on now and
what house bill 436 would change right
um just the facts right and so what I
want to do is take I don't know it's
going to take half an hour an hour or
whatever it takes and give you a lecture
about what's what's in the retirement
system what's in House Bill 436
Etc so
um but what I want you all to do is
listen to what I'm saying and when I say
something wrong
point of order right whatever you know
yeah yeah yeah especially Marty but
everybody
here who thinks one thing and I think if
I say something that's incredible I'm
going to just try to stick to facts
right but
um not not opinion or whatever we that
can be later but but I want to just
explain right and
um and if I get something wrong
you know change fix it right right away
um because as you know you know the best
way to learn something is to teach it
right so that's what we're going to try
to do okay so first point is David you
might want to sit on the side rather
than
that way okay yeah yeah
because I'm going to use these
for illustration here yeah
okay
yeah so it's is this visible the most
if I stood here and
pointed like that okay
all right so let's start probably where
we should start
with
um
people
uh
so
we have there are two categories of
people involved in the retirement system
right one
one are people who are working
and one are people that are currently
retired
and
we we put them into two groups right we
call them
group one
and group two
right and
in general
um group two
are police and fire right and they have
they have a sort of beefier retirement
system because they have very stressful
jobs and they're not expected
I don't know how to put this delicately
but but but they they wear out quicker
maybe and so um so they're not expected
to have a longer as long a career as
someone with it with a less stressful
job right all right Marty one more thing
is they don't participate in Social
Security and they don't participate yes
good point well good point so they so
the working the group one people have
social security
and this is no social security
right good point the life expectancy on
group two on the mortality the 10 years
exactly okay if anyone is to speak would
you please use the microphone because
folks outside can't hear your questions
so yeah if we can leave leave the space
there but what he said was and I'll
repeat it he said in group two these
folks have 10 years less life expectancy
than these so it is a stressful job no
question about it right okay
um
has Social Security no social security
another reason for for a stronger
retirement system okay
um okay now
Within These groups are two subgroups
right so within group two
there's police
and there's five yeah
right
prison guards which is a massive part of
the police side okay they're part of
this yes
right so so like in here
right your favorite documents Steve
yeah no I know but but in here there's
four categories yeah okay and and mostly
in law right they say permanent
policemen permanent firemen Etc yeah
okay all right but they are slightly
different and they have slightly
different uh rates and things like that
okay
um but you but he's absolutely right the
largest or or a very significant group
in this category are Corrections
Officers yeah no question about okay all
right and then in group one
there are teachers we'll put them over
here
and other employees
okay and
so teachers are people that work for
schools right
um and I think not all right there's
some people who work for schools who are
not classified as teachers is that right
yeah yeah you know like School nurses
paraprofessionals okay
office staff yeah exactly so they would
be in this category Marty could I get
you to you're probably going to field a
lot of the questions if you could just
use a mic there or sit at the sit at the
table okay whatever you want
we're having a
current
not a finance discussion and I don't
really understand why that's occurring
here when we have a policy community in
the house that is already embedded and
gone through this bill in extensive
detail well well it's hard it's it's
really hard to appropriate the money
unless the committee the division has a
clear understanding how we got here so
I'm gonna let representative McGuire
continue because I think this may be
helpful to at least those of us on the
division I'm going to get the dollars
and cents before two months all right
all right so
um employees include both state
employees and
um Municipal Employees right the office
staff and and things like that okay uh
teachers uh okay good now according to
this and this is I don't know what it's
dated probably 2020. two
um pretty recent the number of people in
these categories currently we have about
000 in this group
we have about 18
we have about 4 100 in this group
and roughly 1700.
all right and this does not say
um current sort of average compensation
in these groups so we'll leave that for
the moment
um but now we'll talk about retired so
people from this group who made it
through through retirement are down here
and there's currently
uh 27.50 here
foreign
thing I found out
when researching my other bill is that
very few of the people who start working
for the state in this area end up
getting vested and retired right so so
vesting occurs after 10 years and only
about 45 of the people who start here
end up here at the end of the day thanks
remember if I say anything wrong
you know I'm not 100 sure on that
percentage but in terms of the people
who drop out of the system typically
they're going to leave service in their
first you know one to five years when
somebody's here more than five they're
much more likely to invest at 10 but
some people it's not not their cup of
tea so they move on yeah so those are
figures I got from Das fairly current so
so of the people that leave State
service again State service I don't know
about Municipal I would guess they're
roughly the same but it could be wrong
but of people who are leaving State
service this year
65 percent
well a large more than half are
undestined okay
um now teachers teachers are
uh 15
uh 154.
um
very few people leave right once you
start as a teacher you're going to
continue through the through the system
they have a very low low rate uh
leaving in police we have
um
four six
fifteen
something like that
um
these these are a little bit the the
rate at which they leave service I think
is somewhere in between here but it's
fairly close to teachers they tend to
stick around and the number here is
one eight
something like that all right so
um
so you can see that
in these in group one there's a little
bit fewer people retired than are
working in group two it's more equal
right maybe even a little higher on the
retired side now the average pension uh
from from these people is from each is
quite different and remember there's no
Social Security on the on the group ones
but you know I mean there's no Social
Security on the group two side there is
sort of a security in the zone okay so
this is about fifteen thousand
okay
this one is about twenty three thousand
this one is 39 000.
this one is 44th
now I really don't know what's the
average social security benefit of these
people but I'm you know I would guess
it's sort of
makes these all pretty similar anybody
know
no okay all right so um
so that's kind of the the number of
people in the whole system
all right let's move on to how to what
their pension is
so
all right now let's talk about pinch
okay so someone's pension is the
following formula right so the pension
is a number of years of service
hi
um
a uh what does what is called average
final compensation
we'll get into a lot of detail about
that because the definition of that is
key to house bill 436 and so on okay
and
um
times
um some some multiplier
we'll call it m for purposes here
um so that multiplier is also key to
house bill 43
436 right it's changing for the four
group twos okay
um so number of years
however many years somebody works 40
years 20 years whatever okay times
average final compensation some sort of
average of of years and and one of the
details is what's included in that and
how is that limited because there's this
is a very complicated section of law
about what's in that
and then this is a straightforward
number
and so let's talk about that number for
a moment
okay so for group ones
for a while
that number is if you're under
is it 6500 yeah yeah under 65
so the idea is you're not yet collecting
Social Security right that number is
160th
all right so what is that a little
you're less than two percent one point
six five six five something you know
repeating forever five percent okay
all right if you're 65 Plus
it's 1 over 66.
so the idea is you started collecting
Social Security your pension goes down
by
10 something like that that's 1.5 so
yeah
unchanged by house bill 436.
So currently
uh there are two groups of group two
those who are vested
um prior to
is it January 1st 2012 or is it July 1st
January 1st 2012 vested by yeah right so
invested
meeting they have 10 years in right
that's been by
um uh January 1st
12.
all right same groups
um
right
something wrong no yeah that's not right
but keep going well there are there are
multiple groups you have the you have
the medical subsidy group that you're
not including that ended in 2001 you
have the latter Group which is six
different categories and then you have
the post 2011 group so it's not two
okay
so are those things significant yes
those are significant the medical
subsidies okay okay
the medical subsidy difference although
it is true is not really relevant
because that's for a fixed group and it
is not changed by any legislation under
under consideration that's but is it is
it a is it a payment like salary or like
pension or is it a it's a statement it's
a stipend yeah stipend okay yeah it's
it's not part of the core pension
benefit it was something the legislature
added as a supplemental benefit in I
think 89 and then subsequently repealed
for the different groups over different
periods of time but it it's it's one of
those benefits that is not
part of the actual pension it's a
premium offset a stipend you know for
the eligible members so it's real money
for people who would you know who retire
from a town and they're paying less for
their insurance okay you know from the
town but it's it's not it's a separate
it's separate from the pension so
um
six retirees how many are getting
there are approximate approximately
about all counting all groups I mean I
can get a breakdown I don't have it in
front of me but there's there's about
um a little bit under 10 000 retirees
who are subsidily subsidy eligible and
the subsidy only applies if you're
getting insurance from the employer
you're retired from it's not a it
doesn't offset your insurance if you're
working for Fidelity or whatever so
there's about 9 800 people and it's a
closed group essentially oh so some of
them are over here yeah yeah there was
um yeah it was created as a group two
benefit teachers were added a year or
two later State Municipal employers were
added at different periods in the 90s
and taken out at different periods you
know in the early 2000s it's a flat
amount
um if you're subsidy eligible it's up to
375 dollars per person spouses are
included in that you know they can get a
subsidy as well uh for under 65 and once
the subsidy eligible person turns 65 and
Medicare or becomes their primary if
they're getting the Medicare
supplemental plan it's 236 a month is a
is a stipend towards that so it's fixed
dollar amount fixed population
um there are there are
probably a few hundred active group twos
who can retire they had to be in service
on June 30th of 2000 to be subsidy
eligible
some get a little bit more right some
yeah plus
uh a thousand or two right so something
like that yeah 750. yeah you know if
it's if it's a married person at 750 a
month so what's that nine thousand a
year is medical subsidies significant
you know so that yeah okay so for some
there's there's extra in both categories
yeah but that group is never changing
and all that stuff right okay correct
all right
um now
sorry yes sir
if you really want to go back to history
how that started was in 1988 when group
one got the Social Security offset they
had they took money out of the assist
pension fund 20 write down on the
pension fund and to make it fair for
group two because we didn't get Social
Security that's why we got the health
care so they got the Social Security
offset we got the health care and then a
few years later group one complained
because we had health care even though
we got it because they got Social
Security offset they ended up getting
the health care never funded it and um
we ended up where we are now but that's
that's where it started in 1988 uh was
was when they got the Social Security
office said we got the health game we'll
try to push up okay if you paint the
picture we gotta do the whole thing okay
all right so invested two points right
now not invested so
not invested in at 1 112 right so uh
younger than that right if you were not
10 Years yet at that point
uh two percent
well it goes down from 2.4 2.3 2.2 2.1
to 2.0 oh yeah depending on you know
very good so 2.4 2.3
2.2 does not have a grip on this if we
have to keep 2.1
2.0
yeah so there's really three groups
right
there's
kind of another line there
you're right okay so this one
is higher
this day or early yes
let's see the the bottom that where the
2.0 is that's anybody hired after uh
seven one of eleven
seven
eleven
or like
so
um so this is
they were hired
uh before seven one of eleven this room
yeah and not invested by one one as well
it had didn't have ten years in yeah
okay and and they have
these do they have are there some of
those that are 2.0 no no okay so they're
only two point ones two point twos two
point threes and two point fours yeah if
if you if you want to add more
parentheticals that the the the the 2.4
is for people who had less than 10 but
more than eight the 2.3 was less than
eight but more than six
you know
um the 2.1 was zero to 40 but less than
four okay so so that's that's where
there's a tier within a tier there four
is eight plus
we should be teaching
this is
yeah
four clubs
so what about the ones zero to two years
okay it's it's zero to four is the 2.1
so you know that's zero zero to four
yeah I bet yeah
all right so this is the biggest group
of these yeah okay so this has sort of
four years worth of people two years two
years two years yeah like that and
there's there's a minimum retirement age
goes up as the multiplier goes down in
that uh you're probably gonna get to
that but you know yeah
all right yes there's other
um
other requirements okay
so is that enough for that page
so the main point here is that
for this group
um
two percent so so think about it
essentially
um
to get your final compensation your
pension to be equal to your your average
final compensation right at two percent
you'd have to have 50 years of service
right very few people ever would get
that kind of thing right
um some maybe but not too many but here
it'd be 40 years
right so we're talking about like a like
a depending on how you look at it a 20
or 25 difference from from this to that
okay and this is a sliding skip okay
all right
this one
foreign
let's get to the definition of
average final compensation
so
all right
so there are two important definitions
in law
one is called earnable compensation
and the other is called average final
top section
and one feeds into the other
all right
and they are
in uh
RS let's get this right here
this is in RSA
Dash
colon one so it's in the definitions
area
um and earnable compensation is part
17.
and average final computation is part
18.
now
um let's talk about what's in current
law first
so current law
has a two different
um
two different definitions
actually well
okay so it has
two different sections here right
so
it has those who are vested prior to 112
so that's the
before
invested
okay
all right and
um
so the main differences between these
two so
um
is that it's a full base rate of
compensation so basically it's salary
okay
well
over time
uh holiday
station
uh severance
Etc there's a few other things
um
okay
but there are some limitations all right
so limitations are
that
um
are specifically on extra instead of PVP
extra
and special Duty
and by the way
in current law this is the same for
group one and group two
right there's there's not a there's not
a group one difference and a group two
difference it's it's the same definition
of all this stuff okay
um
so up here
the so extra and special Duty as I
understand it that's not overtime right
that's
um
when you're wearing your uniform and
doing other things that's that's
um yeah work done for a third party
that's reimbursed to your employer and
the employer still pays you but it you
know it you know the easiest one is you
know like you know Highway you know you
know they're doing the power lines and I
need somebody to direct traffic so it's
a you know work done for a third party
reimbursed to the town and then the town
pays the the traffic control event or
something like that yeah right yeah okay
so in the case here
um extra and special duty pay
um
is
Limited
during the highest three years of
preventable service
all right so so there's some limits
basically limits
yeah during three years
right versus the high three whichever
the lower percentage
um
there's also a limit in your last 12
months of employment
all right
um
let's see any compensation received in
the final 12 months in excess of all
right it is that
um
in the last 12 you can't have more than
one and a half times the the
um previous 12 months yeah that's
referred to as 150 rules and what you
explained on that extra and special duty
is a seven year averaging those are both
anti-spiking Provisions neither of which
are being removed in 436.
last year
has to be less than or equal to
previous year
just for additional color on that that
was put in in the early 90s and if if
someone ex their payment from their
employer exceeded the 150 cap in their
final year you know just say they
doubled their salary for whatever
reasons they would still be paid that
money from the employer but anything
over that 150 can't be used as part of
the average final comp is Honorable com
for calculating the AFC
so it's it's not like they can't make
more but we can't and the retirement
system can't count it we're talking
about
going into creating this number right
we're not talking about what people
actually get in checks while they're
working yeah they actually get paid for
whatever work they actually do yeah okay
so but this is for the purpose of
calculating how much compensation you
have and basically what's going to
happen is
um you're going to have a certain amount
of compensation each year and then we're
going to take an average of a certain
number of years to get this number okay
so we're going to take this and average
it uh from some number of years of this
to get that okay and then that will
okay all right so now
um let's look at uh these this group The
the more recent uh people the younger
younger people okay
so
um
same thing it's got
it's got salary
um
it's got overtime
it's at uh cost of living et cetera Etc
um
but what it doesn't have
is key things that it does not have is
it doesn't have this vacation and sick
day right so occasion
and sick pay
doesn't have
okay
and I don't see anybody jumping up so I
must be right
um and
um
it is subject to certain limitations
okay there's there's other limitations
go back to black no the same yeah with
the second vacation that it the statute
it distinguishes you know if you if I
had a day off today and it wasn't here
you know that's part of my pensionable
wages because I took the time this this
is unused sick and vacation is what
doesn't count for the the non-vested
people so that's leave accruals that you
have either you get paid out at the end
of your career or some employers make
you you'll pay out every year whatever
so so what we're talking about here is
unused yeah
so this is an aspect of spiking right
because
um
no
I don't agree with that statement okay
all right well we'll just say what it is
so if
you're in this group and you retire with
I don't know six months of vacation
right
um presumably you're subject to the 150
percent rule yes okay always okay so
um but that could kind of get you
towards 150 right let's say your last
year you you work the same as the year
before but you had six months worth of
vacation and sick pay saved up then you
would be at 150 percent in that last
year versus 100 Yes except you can't
accrual vacation time fast no one can
accrual vacation time that fast
so you're not you're acting like you're
in a position where you're going to do
that twice and that's not possible no
employer offers that
are you saying there's a limit on how
much you can approve
I don't know of any municipality nodding
heads in the back I don't know a single
municipality left that does not have
limits or has completely eliminated it
totally okay
so you guys in the back how much a
vacation and sick time can you approve
you can uh
20 years
which is 450.
everybody's different
okay so he said you could Bank 900 hours
yeah and
will only pay you 450 of that out
[Music]
so if you have 900 hours the state will
kill 450 away from you and they will pay
you only for 450 yards at the end yes
okay yeah yeah with with the sea
contract with with most state employees
that there are maximum amounts of
vacation and sick time you can accrue
and the longer you work the higher those
limits get uh he's right that it it and
and for the sick time payoffs with the
state you only receive them from the
state if you go straight into retirement
if you file for retirement before
terminating employment if you are you
know 42 and you're not going to retire
you can't retire that all walks away you
would still get your vacation time paid
out because that was earn time and just
just to to you know every employer you
know has their own policies or their own
contracts their own cbas so they may
treat accruals you know different in you
know Henniker versus Warner versus
Dunbarton you know like they might have
different caps and things like that and
that's something the retirement system
doesn't track
um so you know but it's going to vary
all right so we'll put a we'll put a
little I don't know question mark around
this one so if I may it may or may not
in this representative McGuire yes just
a quick one that is that's all
negotiated mostly through cities and
towns through contractual agreements
sick leave and vacation time and they're
they're all different depending on the
department you're working for right
um yeah so but it's still
for this group
whatever the number is it's included
this group not include but I can tell
you just historically like in Manchester
they would in contracts they would give
us more sick time because they didn't uh
that would be in in lieu of uh overtime
you know so it's all contractual and a
lot of times they gave us sick time to
to save money
um you know it would actually save save
the city money by giving us the sick
days right but the question is how does
it affect tensions well I can tell you
in Manchester weekend accrue I don't
know if it's changed I've been off for a
while but they used to be able to accrue
120 days they get paid 90 when they they
leave but I think that's even changed
now to probably 60. anyways
um
so some of this
when you when you're in this category
some of this can get into your
compensation which will end up in your
pension but in this category none of it
can get into your pension yes
that Prozac yeah so what ends up
happening is instead of a town paying
out unused vacation time at straight
time people take all their vacation and
their Replacements are paid at time and
a half it is done as a cost saving
measure for the municipalities that is
why they do it and it's also in essence
a cost-saving measure for the pension
system because you don't have senior
people getting time and a half to cover
something that could have been cashed
out in stray time that's why this still
exists
and that's why this hasn't gone away
so Steve
trying not to get into why but you why
is part of this that's why that you have
a policy committee to learn about the
why we're trying to do the what at the
at this point okay all right and you're
all when you get you got to do a third
bar because you're missing a big part
here so keep going okay
so um
all right so
um
extra and special right so there's also
uh maybe I should do this in in Revenue
um
so compensation for
learnable compensation incentives
um unusing time conversion yeah so there
there are
um
I appreciate that you read this last
night and you're trying to explain it to
US Representative McGuire but there are
people that have studied this for years
and years and years
but that's what you said you said you
said you went over it last night so I'm
just trying to yeah and so
I think that is I'm sorry to say this
but I think that may be more than my
compatriots
and but if you're talking about a
substantive policy change in a finance
committee based on something you're
trying to explain that you learned last
night Steve please
all right let's just listen to
representative McGuire and okay we'll
keep correcting them but that's fine
thank you
all right so what he's talking about is
um
there's another group after July 1st
right so this is
um
immense service so this is hired
after
seven one eleven
right
hired after seven one eleven
there is no extra and special duty pay
in this calculation right so extra
special
is that
yeah all right
you might want to note that in your
middle box those people that were were
hired
with that in their compensation package
and that is an important part of this
bill so they had that as a condition
upon their hiring
within that time frame that is the cross
book 436 here
is that or call them article 23 people
that might be more appropriate
people whose pensions were retroactively
altered that's that middle group so
let's identify them properly
um
I'd like to explain what's actually in
law
yeah right
um but what you're saying is why such
and such right so I'm trying well just
describe that middle group correctly so
people can understand it okay they were
hired under those conditions
yeah
see that is known and assumed yeah no I
don't know because we're saying that
people on the committee don't not that
are unaware of all the conditions of
this I just want to make sure that it's
that they're getting the full picture
all right so
sort of what he's saying I think is that
this section of law
has never changed for this group is that
right no no see so
so this is the current condition in law
for this group of people yes
yes it is okay
all right this is the condition group
for this group all right
now
all right so that's
um
so there are other
minor this also has this 150 thing is is
throughout right so so
um what I'm writing here is the
differences from this
okay so this is this is the ones that
have in some sense the best deal right
they they have the most things cut
counted in here which feeds into here
which feeds into the pension this has a
little bit less and this has a little
bit less yes okay all right good all
right now let's go to the other side
average final compensation
for this we also have three groups
so we have
um
vested
before same thing right that's invested
before
uh one one twelve
here we have
tired
uh after
seven
uh one
eleven and here we have
um
I'm sorry no here we have miniatures
who have not got oh I'm sorry
the law is written backwards this this
group is written this group is written
before that one
so it's there so um
hired before
seven one eleven this is actually part C
of the law this is part A this is part C
this is part B who knows why okay and um
and this is higher
after
seven one
okay
all right
so
this is
um
three-year average
okay
but
there's sort of a butt here
um
there's some limitations on extra and
special duty pay
in these three years
that's this this thing
this this definition is actually
repeated sort of in here right so the
the seven year average on extra special
duty pay it applies to the what would be
in these three years right so there's
some limitation
okay
um now for this group
um
this is a five-year average
I told you it would be a little long but
I've been interrupt
I understand
you want to take a break no no okay
I get it all right so this and we
haven't even got the house bill 436.
all right
so this is a five-year average not three
right so this is gonna be a smaller
number just from that alone
um
and
there's okay so there's a um
there's a limitation
on this uh this average
and
um
so okay so so they introduce this
concept of Base
Plus
extra okay
maybe we should use the word X base plus
um
Facebook
compensation over base uh
so
you have your base pay but you have all
kinds of extras right and so there's a
limitation on this that's different in
these two cases right so base
plus compensation over base
okay and the limitation in this case
um is on the
um
the the whole career
minus the high five years
no right that was taken out in house
bill 1587. that that's for the bottom
so this is based this limit is based on
the career
again it's backwards because all right
this one is career
minus the high five years okay
so
and this particular little change
career career minus high five years
was added last year a year ago
okay
um and this is
42 million dollars right it was removed
it was changed it wasn't really added or
subtracted the calc was changed right
this calculation would change right a
year ago
there was only one category here yes
yeah right there was one category like
that okay so a year ago
I'm sorry no like this right a year ago
it was like this right if you were uh if
you were vested before three year
average if you were vested afterward
five-year average and the limitation on
on these extras
and the limitation was based on
the way your career was I guess the
concept is
um if you're earning extras in your
final five years the five years that
count
that is similar to the rate you're
earning them in your rest of your career
that's fine right you're you're not
doing anything different in your final
five years but if in your final five
years your earnings
jump compared to the rest of your career
right then they want to limit it okay
for the purposes of your pension right
so but last year
for this particular group this
particular group was created and this is
the group that's affected by House Bill
436 primarily
yeah they took away
the the final five years from this
calculator the the high five they they
made this the entire career rather than
the whole career not including the the
highest five years
okay so that made that made this number
bigger than that number right and so
whatever so but that was paid for last
year
um at about like I said about 40
something million dollars okay
all right
okay
okay all right now let's talk about
House Bill 435
okay
so
House Bill 436 right here
section one
is just the definition
one puts into law invested
um equals 10 years and no changes
three years okay
um so that's that's not all right
section number two changes earnable
compensation
okay the First Column there
so it it has four sections group one
group two well group one prior to a
certain date group uh one after a
certain date group two uh the three
groups right the three the three
sections okay
um and it actually doesn't
uh
there's there's not much change
per se in these sections right and the
these sections are essentially a copying
current law but they're they're in here
for a reason which we'll explain in a
minute
um
but as far as I can tell
these sections are currently copies
uh it breaks them out right there's now
going to be group one before
group one after
um group two before
two middle
and group two after right now okay
but I don't think the way they're
written they're not very different from
what's there
yes
um yeah I think what the bill is do not
in that section but what the bill is
doing is is over year over year
enactments moving some group two members
in that the hired before seven one of
eleven not vested into the uh you know
the the top definition of absolutely so
we're gonna get to that in a minute okay
but but but as far as the bill is
concerned this is just sort of a
restating but it's breaking it up into
pieces because it's going to change who
where's the boundary between these two
pieces
right there
okay so the boundary between the date
is going to change here right so what's
going to happen is people who right now
are in this category using that
definition are going to move into this
group
okay they're going to move into the
group they were hired under yes yes okay
we'll we'll agree on that no okay no
thank you
okay but I don't see but like I said I
don't see any substantive
changes at first to these groups with
with sort of one exception
and that is the date in question any
date that I see this date in the middle
group here
um after 1 1 12 right in the bill it's 1
1 13.
okay now my reading of the bill is that
might be an error okay because later
when we change things we're going to say
go to that paragraph and change one one
twelve to one one something no later it
says one one thirteen to one one
fourteen it is not an error okay all
right we'll we'll look at it
um
all right so anyways the point is all
throughout this section the main change
is that the twelves one one twelve in
House Bill 436 become one one thirteen
which sort of automatically
moves
one year's worth of these people into
this group
okay from from day one sort of from when
the bill passes well the effective date
which is January of 24. okay
which is which is important right and so
the key difference is if you look at
that
what used to be
um
the The Five-Year average for that
particular group will become the
three-year average right and these other
limitations on
um vacation and sick pay uh and special
duty pay and this cob thing
will will go away and become those other
limitations it'll become the 150 rule of
the seven year
okay so right away
for one year's worth it's going to be in
that group okay
all right so and then the same thing
this is section two of the bill section
three of the bill is very similar it
takes average final compensation
and and does the same thing right so
it's
um oops
okay so section three let's see
yeah so yeah that's okay section three
of the bill takes average their house
voted two years
so it takes average final compensation
and
um
it
again breaks it up into these five
groups group one before
well afterwards
middle group
uh two after and and again it's going to
be changing the date of of this divided
right so uh but but I there are some
changes by the way and um including to
um to group one and I think those are
just clean up is that right correct you
would say Marty yeah yeah there was one
definition you know for for that uh
middle tier for a group one in group two
that was consistent but there's certain
pay types that only apply to group one
like uh you know extracurricular um you
know teacher development pay and things
that are only specific to group two like
detail pay So when you buy for Kate the
definition of earnable comp for group
one and group two you want to take the
group two references out of the group
one section and the and vice versa
but as far as I can tell
there's no
no they're not trying to do substantive
changes here right they're just trying
to kind of set up a structure that
things can move okay
now let's get to period to section four
section four is
it
um
there we go so
all right so
um
section four
so this is the section
um
that
all right
says that for certain
um
for for certain
it starts to add age into here right so
um for group two members who are vested
before
um so we're making a group here who are
vested before
uh one one
well
so I guess we're just repeating actually
we're repeating the section of law that
does the percentages right so
um yeah so that's right so this is um
four is doing the same thing for the the
uh
we start out with the group twos right
group two is best before one one
uh
13 from 12 right
and
um then we make another section
for
so this is where the the percentages
this is the section where the the two
and a half percent lives
right
also representative the minimum age in
service requirements are all in that
um 100 A5 section two it's it's um
what was added was a transition table
for those members back in 2011 so
um you know where the when the as the
multiplier change the minimum age and
service each went up a year you know
sort of on a ladder so that this is
moving people off the ladder is that
correct would you call it that Steve
yeah yeah it's an annual transition of
people back to the conditions in which
they were hired originally right okay so
um
so this is where the two and a half
percent is previously it was that you
could retire
at uh 45 years
Plus
20 years of service
okay
um
or
um 50 years
and uh 20-year 25 years of service
and
um
okay or
or 60 years
so
um there's a Year's criteria of when you
can retire okay and it also has the the
two and a half percent stop and it it
makes a second a second section for
um
or other other numbers of years okay
all right
um
but anyways this is the one where this
multiplier is spelled out right so
um this is the one where there's a 2.1
percent there's a two percent
Etc
right
um
and all right
okay
but the the bulk of the action of the
bill seems to be in the in the right in
the following section
so all right so
this is just again it's kind of
repeating current law right with the one
exception of this
but of changing that particular date
but the the following sections are where
the real work of the bill is done yeah
okay so section five is the one we've
already talked about this is the cat
right so for the middle group of group
three
um it's changing the cap from the
current
um 125 120
000.
to 125.
okay let's do it all right
and it's changing uh
the cap
um
and
so so
let's change the capital 100 and it's
changing
um 85 percent
uh cap 200 percent
okay
so
it's under without my Amendment there's
another part
right and without his Amendment which I
haven't introduced to the committee well
we've already accepted it but anyway it
should be explained yeah there's also an
accelerator in here for this hundred and
twenty five thousand
right so 1.25
per year right so so for the for the the
top group here for the for the for the
group ones two before
there's just a limit of of a hundred
percent of salary
in terms of what your overall pension
can be 100 of your highest gear for the
group two mids
um there's currently
um
there's currently the same right the
mids and The Afters are currently the
same and it's 85 percent of salary and
125 000 right whichever is lower the
bill splits those out and makes the mids
120 uh 125
000 and a hundred percent of salary and
the bill accelerates the 125 percent of
salary
for uh I'm sorry the 125 000 to a higher
number over time it representative it
also does something else and this is one
of the concessions that was added the
pension cap did not get instituted until
2009.
and as part of the concessions in this
bill it is being moved back to 2001
prior to 09 there is no pension cap
we are putting eight years of people
under a cap that they were not
previously under
obviously only for those who are not yet
retired
yes yeah
all right so
um
so is this an area yeah I saw that so so
what he's saying is
um currently uh members of commence
service before 2009 have no cap on their
Sal on their pension this is going to
make it a hundred percent for those
before 2001.
right no 2011.
it says 2001 right it's it's in two
parts
notwithstanding before 2001. so if if
under this provision in in the 436 as
you have it now uh without the amendment
um anyone hired
um you know on or after July 1 of 2000
January 1st of 2001 is subject to this
now 125 000 cap folks hired on that date
under current law right now their
pension could end up being more than 125
if if their compensation you know in
their service you know allowed that you
know the formula under the formula
there's no cap in other words right now
for anybody who was hired before
7109 and not vested by one one of twelve
okay so it pushes the cat back for about
eight years but this seems like an error
right because if they're not
um how can you give up something for oh
or have attained vested status I see
okay
it's one of the multiple concessions
that exist in 436 but it seems to me
you're changing something for somebody
who's vested no
that doesn't seem right again
it's the way the way the bill was
constructed there are multiple
concessions within the bill to make this
more to make this work and that is one
of those but we can't ever give back
something from somebody who's festive
right so this is one of the areas that I
think is
we can't violate article 23 of the
Constitution as well and we did that so
if we're going to start imposing rules
then
all right let's let's uh let's move on
but but what you're saying is so in this
particular section the cap is let's just
leave it at that the cap is the key part
of section five
all right now section six is the one
that moves all the dates
right so what the main thing that's
happening in this bill right is that
in the table of 1.2 percent 1.1 percent
Etc
the people in this middle group
over time are moving up the table toward
two and a half percent
okay right right and
and
they're moving from the the middle group
over there right in their way their
earnable compensation is into the top
group
right so they're moving from this middle
group into the group where instead of a
five-year average we now have a
three-year average instead of an average
with
um
with limitations I don't even see where
I put that
um instead of it oh yeah instead of the
the base plus cob thing where we limit
how much extra you can have over your
base we move into the area where it's a
three year average without that
limitation
right so for people in this group for
those that 10-year window of people
um we're moving them into the
um
into the three-year average and without
that limitation
um we're letting them have a vacation
and sick pay count as part of their
earnable compensation
and we're moving them in this table
of toward two and a half percent so so
at the time they're going to retire they
were you know it's done it's done in a
phased way right over over a period of
time but but typically they will get to
the two and a half it's done in a phased
way as part of another concession which
is now taking someone that was normally
hired to work a 20-year career in
forcing them to work to a 22-year career
yes so it is not a full restoration of
their conditions back into the first
group there are not on day one putting
back the law to its state in 2011.
that's true it's over time
pushing the people just in this
particular group towards 2011. but it
also the ones hired after 7 111
unchanged
unchanged okay that's right okay
all right and I think that's it
okay I would I have defended and I'll
continue to defend the legislature's
right to modify the pension system for
folks that have never been hired and
that's what the seven one of eleven
third box is it's folks that didn't
exist
this bill doesn't address those folks IT
addresses the folks that were hired
under a different condition and then had
that modified on them right after they
were employed but the point is
all right now we can start talking about
the financial aspect of it
but
but the financial aspect has several
pieces
right one is
this one the two and a half per the two
percent moving to two and a half percent
right but there's also those
the The Five-Year average moving to
three
the extras vacation sick Etc moving to
the old uh formula
right and the cob limitation going away
right so those are all separate pieces
right and you could
kind of have the bill structure as messy
as it is
um with just some of the pieces and not
others right
no I really can't
okay I see representative Sweeney has a
question or a thought I have a thought
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative McGuire for the
presentation thank you representative
Pearson and Marty for giving us kind of
a full picture of what we currently have
in the system and what 436 attempted to
do uh it is our last day for the for our
division to put together the budget so I
want to propose an amendment to house
bill 2. that can cover areas if that's
the right time to do so or if we want
more discussion yeah absolutely I do
have a quick question for uh
our LBA staff did you ever hear back
from the commissioner of dra as far as
if we move up the repeal of the phasing
out of the IND tax yes and I have a
handout for that would you like me to
pass that out yeah thanks
then representative Sweeney will take up
your emotion perfect
a couple of members who requested a
quick break so we'll take a 10 minute
break okay
all right
sorry representative
do we owe you parking
okay
that we're subsequently we'll call the
division
back together
oh
foreign
representative McGuire everybody here
representative Hewitt
back
so we started a little discussion
earlier and I know representative
Sweeney would like to offer a motion
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
Chairman's in the uh seeking a grand
compromise that can really tackle a lot
of the issues that we're facing uh the
legislature right now I want to move
that we roll into House Bill 2 for the
budget uh the amendment amended version
of 436 from Friday 0891h
but I also want to make a a modification
where the state picks up the subdivision
costs that was increased by the bill and
I also want to in the same motion adopt
the provisions of Amendment
1022h which restored the Communication
Service tax and sped up the repeal of
the interest in dividend Stacks we have
the analysis uh and I'd like to speak to
my mother yeah absolutely I'll second
year
thank you Mr chairman uh we just got the
analysis from the LBA on what the latter
part of my motion would do by restoring
the Communication Service tax in the
budget and speeding up the repeal of the
interested dividends tax to end uh by
this biennium
um and it actually produces relatively a
40 million dollar gain for the State of
New Hampshire uh in doing so which would
provide the funds uh in my recollection
to fund the elements of 436 that would
be rolling into the budget along with
the uh provision that we pick up the
slack that was going to be sent to the
municipalities around six million
dollars or so in 436 to the subdivision
so that's my one motion to do all of
that in one motion so we can have a good
compromise and get good policy done for
the uh for the budget process and for
the state
comments from the division
representative camberells thank you Mr
chair yes I think that that's a very uh
reasonable proposal and that it's a
win-win for everybody so I would like to
uh I would be voting yes on that
representative evil
I really appreciate what you're what
you're doing
um I would be happy to vote for this if
it was just pulling back the CST but I
can't support the the uh up whatever
increasing the um
phase out of the IND I just I feel like
we could do this and just pull back the
CST
representative Griffin
all along I've had some reservations
about 4 36. mainly because we're relying
on
the future legislators
to fund it
but if we restore the communications tax
and dedicate that to the funding of it
I think that's
a compromise at least I can live with
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman
um
you know I will vote for this
um but I it's not my preference
um and there's in for a couple of
different based on details so let me ask
Marty first
um
the
let me see how I can put this
we we don't know
so so in my mind the house bill 436 does
these four things right that we talked
about
changes the percentage from two point
whatever to 2.5 over time
changes the Caps from 85 percent to 100
okay change is the AFC com compilation
calculation and the earnable
compensation calculation okay
in particular the first two I think are
reasonable okay
um but those over there the changes in
in
um uh earnable compensation and average
final compensation
seemed to me to be anti-spiking things
that we are weakening right they were
they were anti-spiking
um Provisions that that this bill
weakens so that spiking can occur more
spiking whatever
um can occur and and they're in two
different ways right as as shown over
there
um and secondly the the provisions that
were done last year in
um
House Bill 1587 I don't think are
unreasonable
and we're very likely to get to get uh
from the from the group after right in
the in the um average final compensation
calculation
as I understand House Bill 1587 was
originally they shaved a little bit of
money last year by carving out that
group
but it's but it's not really reasonable
to to change to make this big change for
this group and not do something for them
too in my mind right and
um
so
you know I I don't like those aspects of
it I don't like the aspects of
um leaving alone the current people
because these are these are people we're
trying to hire under characteristics
very different than than these are
people that are already working Etc
um it's it's gonna make it in my mind
higher harder to hire
if we if we don't improve benefits if
we're improving benefit if we're in the
business of improving benefits we should
do it for people who are trying to hire
now to some extent then then just the
people who are already working and and
and the thing is if we wait let's say we
do this 10 years from now right it's
that much more expensive because we
haven't been saving all along so it's
those two areas that I'm that I have
problems with
represents Sweeney further comment thank
you thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for for supporting the
the motion I mean I'm not in
disagreement that we we need to find a
solution for the the new hires and for
the Post 2011 hires
um that's sort of in that Gap that were
hired and recruited without the promise
uh in place that 436 seeks to restore
um I'm happy to work on other
legislation but I think for for the
budget and for what we can do today this
is a this is a good compromise that
everyone can point to and see something
they like see something they don't like
if we were to each write a budget that
we wanted it'd be 400 separate documents
um so I think I think this is uh I I'm
in agreement with with your comments on
on making it better for new hires and
retaining but I think striking this deal
today is a good move for the state so
thank you
any further follow-up from members of
the division
well I would like to comment I'm in
complete support of this amendment I
want to thank representative Sweeney for
working with me and others
to get to a place I think that works and
corrects a wrong that was done over a
decade ago
and it actually gives us a more positive
balance as we go towards the final
stages of the budget
there has been some concern about uh
moving the IND repeal up that will be a
decision for the next legislature to
deal with we have no idea what's going
on in two years we don't have a lot of
idea what may be going on tomorrow but I
think this is a very good move I think
it's a good compromise and I hope my
colleagues support it thank you when the
clerk is ready I wish oh I'm sorry
representative Hewitt yeah I just want
to say that there's there's more that
could be done for for anybody the
situation here is what made Difficult by
the by the budgetary process that we're
going through and the changes that we're
going to have to make in terms of having
a a satisfactory solution to the budget
budget process in terms of uh House Bill
um
I agree that we need to do something
about the people the new the new hires
uh but of course the people that have
been with us for all these years uh have
been suffering with it for for a long
time and if it if it means that we have
to take a little more time to to make a
solution for the new hires I think that
in this situation we have to do that so
I'm completely in favor of the amendment
Melissa and Mr Hoffman obviously we
don't have an amendment number yet but I
hope that the motion was clear so we
could put something together for us to
look at in black and white but we can
certainly vote on representative
Sweeney's motion so it's
represent Maguire I remember what I
wanted to ask Marty so Marty in the in
the house the fiscal note for House Bill
436 we are lowering the unfunded
liability by 22.7 million right yeah is
that happening
at the end of 10 years or is it now or
how does that the when the when the
actuary
um projects the unfunded liability they
back it into present value of dollars so
that you know the the liability
increases in in today is If You Paid It
Up Front it's it's X
having a 25 million dollar
appropriation over a 10-year period I
think in the original note the actuary
estimated the present value of that
recurring appropriation as 189.7 billion
and again in today's dollars so
um with Representatives Pearson's change
in 0891
um the the 25 million appropriation over
10 years
um does has a has a positive impact it
reduces it's that's overpaying the
liability so essentially you're but
there is you know probably about 1.4
billion on the group two
um in the of the the total unfunded so
you're paying that down earlier in that
22.7 million it's recognized over 20
years but it's lowering the the employer
rate increase
um so it's you know it's not like the
money's going nowhere I mean it's it's
used anything over funding the bill
itself is going towards existing
unfunded which will you know lower the
rates for everyone so that lowered the
uh the employer rate increase from two
point something to 1.6 or whatever is in
that fiscal note yes yeah
so to go to from 1.6 to 0 we have to
extra pay
how much well I the projection
um you know this is based on projected
payroll for fiscal 26. it's on this it
was part of the document that LBA put
together for you yesterday the last page
um which is something I I sent over for
them it showed under the
version of hb436 is adopted by the house
the employer contributions in 26 would
be
14.38 million and with this amendment
that goes down to 9.1 and it's all
normal cost there's no unfunded cost
associated with that so that
um you know so that so that amendment in
and of itself by
taking the escalator off of that
um 125 000 maximum benefit limit reduce
the annual cost in 26 by over 5 million
dollars
okay so so yeah so you think this extra
what did we say six or something yeah
is enough
to change that one point
what was this is the restoring that
other Communications tax
he wanted to just spend just put into
the retirement says house fill 50 style
I guess but just for group twos the
group two unfunded liability
um like an extra six or so six or seven
in order to get that one point seven
percent down to zero
if I could help here this is the
document that was prepared for us by the
LBA which shows the impact of 436 as
amended with
0891h and the the back page the total
impact was about six million dollars in
change
yeah representative grassy any thoughts
yes um Mr chairman
um this is you know I'm I I want to I
want to support this but I think I've
sort of got a knife to my neck right now
because what we've done is I hear the
complaints about how we don't have
enough money to do things we've got
ourselves into a big hole here
and when we take the IND out
um you know accelerate that I think what
we're doing here in this amendment is
asking for a bigger shovel so we can
keep digging a bigger hole we've
listened to these problems that we have
with deficits and funds we have an
opportunity to address them and we're
ignoring that but because we have to
find a tax cut someplace and I think
that the money the numbers that we see
here that for the future we're basically
digging that hole deeper so that future
legislations legislatures are going to
be even in more trouble as far as trying
able to fund programs such as this
I will vote for this bill
but I will not support and if there's
any effort to take the interest in
dividends tax acceleration out I will
support that because I think it's this
is the wrong thing to do
but this is a good bill and we need to
get it passed
thank you representative grassy uh
seeing no further comments if the clerk
is ready to call a roll and again our
lva folks will be getting the black and
white version of this to us once we vote
Yes Melissa okay
clarify just to make sure we're doing
the amendment correct you want to
terminally fund the bill essentially so
not having any cost to the municipality
as it is right now where it has an
additional 7.5 million costs two minute
you to the municipalities each year you
want to terminally fund that for the
state correct
thank you thanks Melissa anything Mr
Kaufman
thanks okay if the clerk is ready to
please call I just need to clarify in my
own mind so we have HB 436 we have this
amendment
0891h that we adopted last Friday last
Friday and what this amendment this um
1022h does is it moves 436 into HB 2 or
no sorry so my motion was to take 436 as
amended on Friday put it into hp2 take
1022h put that into hb2 and restore and
and absorb the municipal and political
subdivision costs of 436 into the budget
so it's really three things in that one
motion uh in the in the seeking of a
compromise
thanks representative Sweeney
are you all set
could there be any interest in just
splitting up the motion and just having
one relating to 436 as amended and not
including your motion on the pain
I I'd like to make this motion and have
this vote on this motion first and then
no problem depending on it we can we can
I just was asking it's an important
point
yes Marty just just as as a as a caviar
I just would just want to mention you
know when we're talking about future
retirement costs there are a lot of
actual assumptions that go into that you
know those assumptions may be monitored
you know maybe modified due to cause
over time if if uh circumstances change
so I I I I understand representative
sweetie's intention to terminally fund
the bill going forward but
um the the 26 employer rate increase
um you know that's based on the payroll
in 26 and then the the in our rates are
assessed as a percentage of covered
payroll so the payroll is going to grow
every year at a certain amount and I
don't know what you know the the tax
changes and the other Amendment you know
what the what the future Revenue
projections are for that what I'm saying
is you may be terminally funding it you
know but that may change over time just
you know you may be over funding it you
know or you know type of thing but it's
like what aren't you decide so they
couldn't can't guarantee terminally
funding because
things may change you know over time
yeah as you know as you've seen in the
past the legislature next time may do
something totally different we can only
tie our hands we can't tie theirs yeah
represent Maguire yeah so I'm worried
that the number we have on this page the
six million dollars that's a one-year
number not a terminal number is that
correct Mark that's correct yeah
that's the that's the employer projected
employer rate increase in fiscal 26. you
know and that that percent of pay that
1.6 a 1.67 would be you know projected
to be stable over you know the next 10
20 years but as payroll grows you're
you're it's you know in actual dollars
it's going to be more but as a percent
of the covered payroll you know that
that you know will be be flatter so if
you
you know if you're paying 10 of a
million dollars and then you're paying
10 of 2 million dollars you know you're
paying 200 100 000 more 10 years from
now you know that's just you know it's
it's how it goes but you know with
inflation and other things
it's not the same because you you know
200 000 isn't worth 100 000 is now yeah
there's all kinds of
but present value and future value
issues baked into that math but doesn't
the words terminally Fund in this motion
change the six million dollars to 60
million dollars today yes
or something like that
yeah I'm kind of kind of digging a
little deeper into some of the math that
I'm you know comfortable kind of
guessing at at least without a pen and
an envelope in front of me
um you know but but the employer rate
increase isn't a one-year increase you
know that's that's you know that that's
the point you know that basically the
the 1.68 and 1.67 is the cost of the
additional benefits gained by the middle
tier as a result of this bill for their
service going forward up until they
retire
you know it's it's you know there's no
it's not the unfunded piece of it that
that's covered plus with the 25 million
so this is this is future accruals you
know if you were funding it on a
year-over-year basis how much do we need
to put aside for this member next year
the rate should be X so um you know it's
you know it's it's two different things
and the normal cost is dependent on you
know all the assumptions and and so the
intent of terminally funding it today is
you're temporarily finding it today
based on current assumptions and that
that's fine and that's what the
legislature's always done
um so so that's not let me use the
analogy of House Bill 571. 571 was
terminally funded at 84 million dollars
yeah for a benefit that was roughly
eight or nine million dollars per year
right yeah for for that particular group
so so my point is the bet the yearly
benefit was eight or nine the terminally
funded cost was 80 four yes yeah so so
therefore representative Sweeney I would
hope from your motion we could remove
terminally funded and make it a fixed
amount so therefore it's easier to
calculate and we know what we're getting
into sorry and and for clarity my my
intent was to fund it within this budget
that we're building not future year like
not fund the future years in this budget
just the the sixth or the Six Million
municipalities and the 1.2 million to
the counties so all the political
subdivisions I want to fund that in this
budget not terminally for the next 10
years
at once right but
it's not going to zero out the one point
something percent forever that's the
point you see what I mean it's a much
bigger number
today to do that then I think you
anticipate I I want to make sure that we
are covering the political subdivision
costs of 436
within this budget for the net for the
two budget fiscal years that we're
dealing with okay just for these two
years just for these two years and I and
not for forever correct I want to be
clear on that okay so that's more like a
12 million for example I think sure yes
all right are we clear about that yeah
okay good perfect
foreign
just because we need to be crystal clear
here
I'm going to ask uh representative
Sweeney to restate his motion absolutely
I am moving to adopt House Bill 436 as
amended by zero eight nine one H into
hb2 with uh for the fiscal years 24 and
25 the state absorbing the cost of the
municipalities in 436 and adopting the
provisions of amendment
1022h to House Bill 2 to speed up the
phase out of the interest of dividends
tax and restore the Communication
Service tax in house bill 2.
the Motions been made in second did you
have any further comment does anybody
have so I just need to say that I
appreciate the what you're trying to do
I really appreciate that you're trying
to cover the municipalities I appreciate
everything
I have a real problem with um having the
phase out of the IND moved up by two
years we have a real concern about
revenues and um you know I don't want
anybody here to think that I'm not in
support of HB 436 but it's the this
particular funding mechanism if it
didn't have the IND in it and we worked
out something else I would vote for it
but I just wanted to clarify why I will
be voting against the uh Amendment thank
you
thank you Mr chair and I would just like
to say for the record that if it went
the way that representative evil would
like it I would not vote for it so
all right
now seeing no further questions or
comments when the clerk is ready please
call the rule okay so
um this is an ought to pass
motion on amendment 10 22 h
right
and
ants rolling 4 30.
okay all right so let's see how should
we do that so there's no there's yeah
there's no specific amendment number yet
what will happen is the LBA will get
this together and we will have a
specific amendment number all right all
right so we're going to vote on rolling
HB 436 into hb2 as amended the other day
by whatever that was oh one eight nine H
right and including the funding
mechanism that's included in 1022 h
right okay
all right although all right represent
Maguire yes representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative grassy yes representative
Hewitt yes spark votes no representative
klichmann leishman yes yes okay so one
two three four five six seven to one
the motion passes
thank you okay and thank you and uh we
will break right now uh we will
reconvene at one o'clock we'll take up
571 that's one of our big issues on our
plate and also oplc
okay thanks everybody for your patience
machines
thank you
because
we're going to go upstairs
foreign
I don't know
you know what my Marvel's on this thing
you know that I was going to benefit
yeah
inspiring
bigger than this one yes what does his
desk at home look like representative
McGuire it's it's sort of like yours but
more so
um
and I explains a lot
so we'll take up 571 first try to
dispense with that I believe
representative McGuire has an amendment
I do if I knew where it was
Melissa could you I see you've got a
good stack you just I guess re-hand out
again thanks appreciate it
okay
right
thanks Mr Hoffman thank you sir
thanks Melissa
are these
competing oh I see that
all right representative McGuire I see
we have two amendments here oh
foreign
so we're gonna begin our deliberations
on representative McGuire's he's got two
amendments I'm not sure which one he
would like to speak to first but
representative McGuire
thank you
um I believe let's let's start with well
maybe I was just explain what the two
are they're quite similar so if if you
recall
um House Bill 571 is a cola for group
two retirees who are retired 10 years or
more
and it has two steps in it one is the 10
to 19 group and one is the 20 plus group
and the way it currently is is a five
percent increase for the 10 to 19 group
and a 10 increase for the 20 plus group
so
um and it's also a permanent Cola so
therefore it's uh the total cost is
quite high it's 84 million
um so both of these bills uh make it a
one-time payment
um
and
um they also put in a cap so that total
um uh pension plus the supplement will
not exceed a hundred thousand dollars
um and they the the simpler of the two
bills is uh 1097 H and that one simply
in the first group the 10 to 19 group
the supplement is two thousand dollars
and in the 20 plus group the supplement
is three thousand dollars
okay
in the other Amendment
the uh 1100h
so with the same thing in the 20 plus
group The the supplement is three
thousand dollars but in the 10 to 19
group the supplement is a ramp so it it
starts for 10 years
um 10 years uh retired would be eleven
hundred dollars 11 years retired would
be thirteen hundred dollars 12 years
retired fifteen hundred dollars and so
on so it ramps up to the hit three
thousand so there's no big step you know
it's not like somebody who's retired
um 19 years and and the uh and a half
compared to somebody who's retired 20
years
there's not a a giant difference there
it's it's more of a smooth smooth ramp
so I guess I would prefer the smooth
ramp type and that is so I'll move house
bill I'll move Amendment 1100h
I'll second it for discussion but I did
have a question the financial impact
representative McGuire
uh thank you I don't know specific the
one part of the bill that I don't know
is the cap on a hundred thousand dollars
I don't know exactly how that would
affect
um the total but it's roughly nine
million dollars
um for the for the one one-time payment
because we have an exact number of the
people in the first in in the 10 to 19
and 20 plus and if you multiply those by
three thousand and two thousand you get
roughly nine million so your Amendment
for identified as Eleven Hundred is
roughly 9 million is that what you're
saying yes it may be slightly less
because I don't know how many retirees
hit the hundred thousand dollar cap I
expect it's very tiny it's a very small
number thank you
questions from members of the division
I have one yes representative Hewitt
that was good A lot of people like to do
that
um
I've been reading these amendments that
they they look the same tell me how how
they're different as yeah
so they're different in section
um one one a okay so notice that in
Amendment 1097 H the amount of the
supplemental allowance shall be two
thousand dollars
okay
in in the other one the amount of the
supplemental allowance shall be two
hundred dollars times number of years
since retirement date minus nine hundred
dollars that's the difference okay so
one has a little calculation the other
one has a fixed flat you know but but
the calculation creates a a slope where
the two thousands in the middle right
then it goes from one thousand up to
three thousand okay
yeah I just wondered how you picked 900
dollars
well I just picked
I sort of from the other the reason I
picked two for the other Bill we started
with the for the simpler Bill the two
thousand and the three thousand I picked
those numbers such that
the total cost of the bill was roughly
one year's worth of benefit
to compared to the original House Bill
571 right and so by making those numbers
two thousand and three thousand it made
that it made the calculation work right
okay so therefore in making the one with
the ramp
I said to myself all right we want to
ramp something up to 3 000 where it
averages two thousand therefore it
should probably start at one thousand if
you see what I mean right so we want to
ramp one thousand up so the middle point
is two thousand so therefore the two
bills cost the same
so
not seeing any further questions uh
Melissa Mr Hoffman uh any idea where we
might get a rough fiscal note
smarty that question that would be
I know you'd love to so please
well if you're voting on it today you
won't have a physical note but if if you
choose this amendment this is something
we wouldn't have to send out to the
actuary this would just take a you know
a day or two of quenching some numbers
and then having somebody you know check
the math but because it's a head count
type thing like how many people were
registered you know between you know 10
and 11 11 and 12 and then multiplying it
by the amounts so
um you know if either one of these we
could crunch it roughly you know in a
couple of days so if you know by the
time it gets father along
hey thanks Marty
seeing no further question a motion's
been made and seconded are you all said
Madam Clerk and this is on
Amendment 2023-1100h
representative Maguire's first
yes
sir McGuire yes representative Griffin
yes representative
yes
representative cambrell's yes
chair Leachman yes
the vote being eight to nothing the
motion passes the amendment of
571.
thanks representative McGuire you have
another one I believe what in 2 30. is
that correct 250 sorry well we already
did that one all right sorry so we
already acted on 250 we just delayed
voting it on the in the big committee
um I'm not specifically proposing any
any changes to that I'm I'm still happy
with it I think it's correctly written
and so on
um but there there are other opinions in
this room so if anyone else wants to
offer some change I could we can talk
about it
yes represent camber else yes thank you
Mr chair
um so I have a couple of things to say
and uh so the first thing is that I'm
I'm going to be withdrawing my
suggestion that we make the this is
House Bill 250 we're talking on uh to do
this sixty thousand dollars per year I'm
going to be withdrawing that that
recommendation
um what I would like to do is to
reconsider uh the amendment that we
passed the other day the amendment 2023
1045 H and I would like to speak as to
why I would like to make the
reconsideration motion representative
Griffin second sure
motion thank you
um
and I'll be the first one to apologize
to the stakeholders and to this
committee because shame on me for not
having really read the original bill
that clearly and also
um As I understood the amendment when
representative McGuire put it forth to
me it looked great I thought it was him
doing something good that was very fair
uh not understanding that some of the
language that he changed in the
amendment meant something to me that
meant something different to the
stakeholders so for that reason uh in
going back and looking at the original
Bill uh the original Bill had nothing in
it in regards to group one and it had a
original language uh
that that was basing the death uh the
death benefit on the words annual rate
of earnable compensation
which representative McGuire uh changed
in his Amendment and after having the
great dissertation this morning and
learning about the system and learning
what those two things meant
um
it is my consension that the original
bill was good as as was uh it limits our
liability because it's only the group
two it doesn't include group one
I will argue that group one never made
any motion to be included on the bill
nor did they have any Representatives
here
so and I will remind the committee that
the initial bill the original bill
passed committee 15 to 5 and it passed
the house 260 to 103. so very very
bipartisan and very large margin of so
in the interest of time I would like to
uh
reconsider the amendment so that I can
make another motion to it all it
so that we could get back to the
original bill
any further questions comments represent
Maguire so I I still like the amendment
um it it makes a few changes to the
original Bill and first of all it does
add
um it does add group one
to to an increased benefit so current in
current law we we've discovered by the
way
um there are currently 19
we'll call them widows I mean some could
be widowers or children or other kinds
of beneficiaries but
um there are 19 widows of group two
members who are uh accidentally killed
um and there are 13 group one members
receiving these kind of benefits
under current law the group two members
and the group one members
um the the benefit is based on is 50 of
compensation but for some quirk in the
way that this is a long time
long-standing benefit right it's been in
in law for many for decades
um but for some Quirk the the group one
benefits are based on average final
compensation the right side of that
chart group two benefits are based on
earnable compensation the left side the
main difference between the two sides is
the right side is an average of could be
three could be five highest years of pay
with some limitation and the left side
is just a number related to one
particular year of service the the final
year of service okay so there's a
difference there and and so that's what
current law is fifty percent of the left
side for group two the right side for
group one
so the amendment does uh two things
first of all for both groups it changes
the 50 to 100 percent
okay that's what was in the original
bill
but it adds
some limitations
because we've discovered that
certain beneficiaries
are through a quirk of whatever you know
the
um their spouse's salary was in a
particular year are sort of way up here
and and the bulk of beneficiaries are
kind of down here so of the 19 in group
two as we understand it the total
benefit those 19
widows receive is about 600 000 a year
so roughly each one is say thirty
thousand dollars a year okay but there's
one of the 19 who is
in like a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars a year based on the 50
calculation and therefore if we were to
pass the Bill like it is not that that
Widow would change I mean that that
Widow is but but if a similar
circumstance comes up later that person
could be a two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars here for example which
seems like why should one be treated so
much differently than the others right I
mean all of them this is a a pension in
some sense for death so so it the bill
has a cap of 85 000
um for both group one group two and
um the reason I picked eighty five
thousand dollars was simply because I
thought that
um a hundred thousand dollars is a nice
round number this this uh pension is not
taxable so so 85 000 not taxable is
similar to a hundred thousand taxable
all right so there's that the other
change in the bill is that
um the the both sides both group one and
group two would use
um average final compensation rather
than earnable compensation and the
reason for that is
um that essentially what we're creating
here is a pension
right we're creating a pension for
widows
and
um we don't we deliberately don't create
pensions based on one year of service
right because that one year could have
all kinds of of odd changes right a lot
of maybe a lot of overtime a lot of
special Duty a lot of whatever or maybe
less right maybe maybe that particular
year
um you know somebody took uncompensated
time off or something right so so it's
generally we don't create pensions based
on one year we do it on an average so
it's more like
the the overall earnings of the of the
person right so so that's why our
pension formula uses the average final
compensation not earnable compensation
and since this is a kind of a pension
it's a pension for widows
it seems to me that average final
compensation is correct so therefore I I
I think the bill is correct now
one um
one criticism by the we've heard this
afternoon uh or this morning was that
group one and group two should have
different characteristics because one's
in Social Security and one isn't right
and so you know that that's not
unreasonable
um we we expect that a social security
death benefit is somewhere on the order
of uh maybe twenty five thirty thousand
dollars a year something like that so if
we wanted to change the cap or the
percentage slightly for group one group
two you know
I suppose that would not be unusual
unreasonable but I don't think it's
unreasonable as it stands thank you Mr
chairman
representative camber else thank you Mr
chair with respect to my esteemed
colleague
um
you're treating it as if we have to use
the same type of formulas to do pensions
when I'm a person who likes Simplicity
the bill has originally structured is as
simple as can be the formula is simply
you take the last 12 months of their
salary and you multiply it by a hundred
percent done simple there's no reason
for why a death benefit like this yes I
will agree it looks similar to like a
pension plan payout but it doesn't mean
we can't use a different formula for it
and their status the stakeholders here
are completely satisfied with the
current way and the current language so
I would I would default to them because
they are the experts
representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman I have a question for
representative McGuire would you be
amenable to
for group two swapping annual rate of
earnable compensation at the death of
restoring that for average final
compensation but keeping the cap in it
seems to me in my my read on what the
stakeholders are opposing might be wrong
but it really does seem getting that
annual rate of earnable compensation at
the date of the member's death is is
what they is what people want to see so
if we swap that out keep your cap idea
and to make sure that your scenario of
the 240 000 payout per year won't be
happening would that be something
you could agree to
thank you for the question
representative
um I would vote against such a thing for
the reasons that I just gave that it
doesn't seem right to leave a widow at
the mercy of
exactly what the circumstances were on
one particular year when it when it
could be
um an app you know the average the
single year could easily be lower or
high or higher than than the average
right and so
um
rather than their general standard of
living sort of
which is what the average creates if you
see what I mean
and and realize again we're we're making
we're doubling the benefit
which has been in law for decades right
so this is a significant increase
whichever way that go that particular
phrase goes
Marty you
would you like to weigh in on this
Marty
yeah I just um I certainly be glad to
answer any questions before that they'll
just say that for the record nhrs
doesn't have a position on the original
bill or the amendment this is the policy
decision
um when you're putting you know price on
you know someone's life and line of duty
that's that's a lot to put on and it's
it's on on you also you know we don't
have a right or wrong answer for that
it's like you have to weigh that
yourselves
was some concern expressed by some that
the new language would prevent someone
from getting this benefit uh the way
it's written if they didn't have uh
sufficient time like 10 years of service
yes
our reading of the amendment is the the
qualification for it is in section uh 1A
and 2A of 188 this this amendment is to
section B which is the actual benefit
amount but the circumstances the death
that section doesn't say anything about
vesting now and it wouldn't under this
circumstance the the question may have
been if someone didn't have enough ears
to have a full AFC heavy penalizer they
get zeros for some of that time and no
it's like in under current conditions
whether it's a you know a death a
disability or some other situation where
somebody doesn't have the three or the
five years you know we prorate that to
how many years they have of service I
mean in the case of somebody who was you
know killed in their first month there
would be a month of salary that we'd
extrapolate into it in ASC but we you
know we don't people don't get zeros if
they have less than three or five years
and then the bill wouldn't
make this only for vested members the
The Accidental I mean the non-accidental
death the non-job-related death you know
you could get a disease or something
that has always had a 10-year you had to
be vested to apply or to receive those
benefits so that that's a different
section of the statute not this one
thanks for clearing that up um other
members of the division please
representative kimbrells well John
having said that our final Financial
standpoint adding again one of the
changes it made was adding group one we
just added more liability when uh it
wasn't requested uh if we keep it to the
original Bill the uh the on a financial
standpoint we will only have that
liability to group two if group one
wants it they can come next year and
file a bill and ask for it but for there
was really no reason to include group
one and again they do get the social
security benefit whereas group two does
not
from The Division I was just speaking
for myself I actually like
representative McGuire's amendment I
know the folks from group one didn't ask
but I think if we can make something
better sometimes it works and as I've
mentioned before we're kind of an unruly
group so we sometimes step outside the
rails but
representative McGuire anything further
foreign
no other questions uh representative
cambrell's and it was seconded by
representative Griffin asked that we
vote to reconsider our actions on the
McGuire amendments which was 1045 h
m
do we want to show of hands or do we
want to vote probably a vote well we'll
have a vote okay
yep sure
when the clerk is ready
okay so we're Mo we're voting on a
motion to reconsider the McGuire
amendment to 250 10 45 H the motion was
made by a representative Campbell's
seconded by
Senate Griffin okay
um representative McGuire no
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrell's yes
representative grassy no
representative Hewitt yes
clerk votes nay
representative Lee Schmidt no
okay so it's five to three
so the motion to reconsider I mean four
to four okay so where does that
uh the motion being four to four the
motion fails
all right
moving right along you don't have
anything else do you represent I just
want to tell the people on the other
side obviously they can bring this up
again in the full finance committee yeah
okay thank you
we don't have any more retirement bills
I believe oh I'm sorry
Melissa we do not have any more but I
did have a question for you
um for the amendment that was adopted
for 571 do you want that as is or would
you like that added to hb2 because
there's a physical impact
uh division preference representative
with why are you yes hp2 please
hb2 thank you
I was um
representative McGuire yeah so that's a
question as to whether 250 would be
appropriate for hb2 or not because it
it's really just a policy thing it
doesn't have any fiscal note well it has
a maybe it has a fiscal note but it
doesn't have a sort of an immediate cost
right so it's it would only be suggested
Standalone yeah stand alone okay that's
fine with me
all right um
I think we're ready to move to
oplc
yeah
finish the easy stuff last yeah
representative Griffin
I would like to make a motion
regarding oh plc
I would like to move the proposed
amendments
number one
two and four
that we receive from Eda
most Amendment numbers uh
uh one zero zero seven h
uh oh nine six nine h
and
one zero one one eight
representative Griffins you'll just back
you up a little bit we're just getting
our papers organized and if you could
run those numbers by us again please
we're talking about amendments one
two and four
that we saw last Friday that were
proposed by Edna all right and uh
the numbers are
one zero zero seven h
0969h
and one
zero one one h
I guess I'll second that
and the motion was seconded by
representative McGuire
let's see here some discussion
you know we're trying yeah we'll give
we'll take a little breather here we get
a lot of papers in front of us while
we're doing that
yeah this is what it looks like we got
them Friday yeah would representative
Griffin like to speak to his motion
hmm I would I think those three
amendments
address
what we've all heard
in emails and telephone calls
and um
uh
as far as the rest of the items and
in hb2
their policy issues
I don't think Finance should be involved
in them
and
the governor obviously approved him and
won some
so
I guess that's my case sir
thank you I'd like to call and
represented groda and representative
Carol
McGuire if you could both sit up at the
table please
so I'm sure there are some questions and
I
believe some of the division members
might like to get
um
yes it's um 11 26.
Amendment I don't know
Amendment one is I'm sorry
representative McGuire group we're still
having some trouble with some of the
members for finding that document that
you presented last Friday do we have any
extra copies of Melissa yeah yeah right
one two and four yeah
they prefer this one representative
sweetie that's more comprehensive yeah
he moved from one two and four oh okay
I don't know about that they haven't
said anything
yeah
and those are all pretty innocent
correct yeah
how are we going to deal with it which
we did talk about right we didn't talk
about it but this is one way the other
way it's just salute the second
if we take it out
we can revise the board right I'm
talking about this I think this is
thank you
so we've asked you to take the C to
answer any questions perhaps on some of
the items that
are referenced and representative
Griffin's motion I noticed Amendment two
it says not fully vetted so I'd like to
get your
take on the not fully vetted
representative Rhoda
thank you the committee felt that
one time the board of psychology and the
board of mental health were separated
and this bill merges the two
and because there was an a concern that
this could hadn't been
vetted well
that it should be separated out of the
bill and we've put together upon your
approval of course a subcommittee to
looking on this at this particular part
of house bill 2.
I would like to add that that section
also adds to that merge board the board
of licensed Alcohol and Other Drug
counselors which is something that has
been considered multiple times in the
past and never accepted
so we would like to take it take a shot
at dealing with this it doesn't have any
fiscal impact that I can find none of
that language adds or deletes a license
it merely restructures the boards
so we don't think it it should bother
you if we take it out of your bill
okay I I just want to say I really
appreciate you all the time that I know
both of you have spent trying to deal
with this huge task and I understand
that the chair has
named you as I guess what the
subcommittee chair to start looking at
this so people can get it
these three amendments were essentially
unanimous in Edna that
um
the technical changes in Amendment one
pulling out the board of Mental Health
we had a show of hands and 15 people
from the committee immediately said yes
we need to deal with that and the other
five may have been just been slower I
couldn't tell there was no objection to
pulling that out Amendment four is the
lnas uh that's the simpler way to deal
with it just pull out the section that
changes the Board of Nursing we've
received a great deal of of information
on that regarding the certification and
the use of lnas and we think it
we think that the language that's
in-house built too is a little abrupt
next for your candor
representative Dan Maguire thank you so
notice that all three of these
amendments we're talking about are
deletions primarily right they are
removing things from from the uh bills
so so if you voted against them you
would be saying I want to leave that
section in House Bill too as opposed to
I want to remove right so yeah the only
obvious uh fiscal note is on the First
Amendment where Edna was unanimous and
saying if there are any licenses deleted
the fee needs to be re
restored to the people who had you know
in some cases may have just paid for it
last week
um the we spoke about that with the oplc
and they would rather just refund the
whole amount than spend the labor to
prorate them and I think most people
would agree with would be happy with
that result
thanks representative McGuire
uh
representative evil
um
so
a vast swath of the PLC section in hb2
that's if we voted
to put to pull these out of hb2 isn't
there still a lot that's left yes that
you haven't really had an opportunity to
fully vet in your committee
correct but we did do triage and these
are the items that came out as urgent
we do not the the technical changes in
Amendment one we want we passed several
bills or one case killed a bill we
wanted to put the house make sure the
house policy was reflected we wanted to
not have duplicative language in House
Bill 2 and House Bill 655 because that's
always a nightmare to keep in mind
and the red the other ones are mostly um
edit editorial changes
so um I think we heard from many people
who in the hearings that we've had on
two successive Fridays whose livelihoods
would be affected by what would remain
in hb2 if we only pass these amendments
uh I don't doubt that most of those
people attended the two hearings that
Edna held on this section uh and we
heard we've gotten the same Deluge of
emails the thing is that that
uh
none of those Rose to the level of
urgency as these the board of mental
health was was a specific issue the LNA
license was a specific issue there were
members of the committee who were
concerned about other
sections
but they didn't get get the consensus of
the committee
fair enough thanks representative so if
I could if I could add so House Bill 655
was a massive bill because you have an
hb2
and
the amount of
changes in the bill
in relationship to the amount of time
that we had to review those changes and
the amount of time that we had to work
with those people involved was
disproportional
so
we met as a we met we had some we had
two sub-committee sessions
and what the results of those two
subcommittee session was Amendment one
right so that's
that took some time and that is what the
first 12 pages of house bill
about the oplc part
and then it was definitely a concern for
some of the members that the mental
health board was being merged and then
there was also a concern for the lnas
but really
you know we didn't come to a consensus
because at that time we really wouldn't
have had enough time because of the
amount of decisions that had to be made
so triage is a word to use however
there's a lot to be said with the
changes that are in-house Bill too
um and um so that's something I think
you need to consider and it's something
that we spoke about last Friday right I
mean how much time do we
you know do we have on something like
this right
which is massive
representative evil follow up so
um one of the things in hb2 was that for
a lot of the boards there was a change
for disciplinary actions from the board
to the executive director and we were
we've gotten an awful lot of emails from
people who were really concerned about
that yes we have too the thing is that
that was one of the central parts from
the study committee on oplc organization
and the reorganization which is in house
bill 655.
the
especially for the smaller boards they
don't have the capacity or the
distance from the affected people in
many cases to in order to investigate or
to hold a hearing so we can we
pulled the investigatory
um
part of discipline away from the boards
and had the oplc hire professional
investigators from the profession who
had the skill who knew about what was
going on
in order to investigate it in many of
the professions it's hard to find
somebody who is not related or connected
with
everyone else in the profession so we
might have to go out of state to hire
somebody
but that was a deliberate decision that
the board should not be responsible for
the investigation they are still
involved in the discipline by a long
shot
even the advisory boards are involved in
discipline
the but this just gets a more
organized
um
approach to discipline and more and it
consolidates it in the oplc where you
can share your investigate the the
hearings officers and so forth a great
many of the boards don't get very many
complaints
something to be proud of really but it
means if they do get a serious complaint
they have to dust off their manuals and
figure out how to how to handle it and
so having a hearings examiner would be
useful
so there's two comments that I want to
make about that
um it's true that some boards
um could become advisory boards based on
the amount of work that they have and
the and the availability of people to
come to advise you to come to board
meetings is
can be than necessarily but can be
difficult however there have been two
things that have been passed this month
this this session which I hope I'll go
through
is that it's to allow virtual meetings
of state agencies
and to allow virtual meetings of boards
so those two things I hope will help
but and although the study committee
made a result you know result made these
recommendations those recommendations as
much as we
would um
we respect the work that the committee
commission has done or the committee has
done we as a board Heaven at me as a
committee haven't looked at them and the
fact that no boards were consulted
per the testimony is concerning to me
because I certainly would want to have
input from them as well
representative Dan Maguire and thank you
Mr chairman so I want to ask you to
um
how would you predict if if this section
of House Bill 2 was a bill in your
committee next year do you think that
the remaining parts
that this amend these amendments leave
in are likely to pass
uh are likely to be chopped up a little
are likely to be just rejected
altogether what do you think okay so are
you tell are you are you saying that the
things that are left over after we do
the
um I think that there would be an
Earnest effort to look at them and take
them as recommendations
I mean we all we all recognize that oplc
is an organization that needs to
function efficiently right at the same
time we don't want to make a burdensome
for the public or for businesses at the
same time we want to make sure that
proper
um
safety measures are put in and that
um you have adjudication and
investigation separated they can't be
together something that we haven't
talked about is that those two things
are now being joined in the Board of
Medicine with the elimination so these
are all things these are all big
decisions and I would certainly
um from my part and I'm sure from chair
Maguire's part we would work together on
it to make sure that it was you know
something that was worked for everybody
my analysis would be that some parts
would just sail through as good ideas
some parts would be reworked extensively
and some parts would be uh battle to the
death
so
Mack Fowler
yeah
yeah so
my judgment I I guess I'm going to have
to vote even though I second I'm gonna
have to vote against this motion because
my judgment is I mean they're talking
about not having enough time
you know whatever they have we have a
tenth of that right so it's like we have
another two hours here or something so
um and then there's also
you know like it or not there's the
political aspect of we have to find
180 90 votes to pass a budget right and
and it it would be chaos for the state
the budget is a plan for how we display
State Financial Resources over two years
and it would be kind of chaos if we
don't have such a plan right so we
shouldn't
put things in that that have no ask you
know that don't seriously touch on
finances
that would
um cause people not to vote for the
budget right I mean it's that simple
right and and the question is if we pass
these things is it more likely a gain or
a loss
and I you know my unfortunate judgment
is it's a loss and so
um
you know I'm I'm strongly in favor of
this kind of thing but unfortunately at
this time
it's a problem thank you Mr Freeman
representative evil
um I agree with representative Dan
Maguire I think that um too much has
been put into hb2 too quickly it's
policy and I believe that if we vote in
favor of the policy we own the policy
and I'm not willing to own vast swaths
of what is put in in because we haven't
had time to analyze it and we don't have
the expertise that e-dna has and
it doesn't sound like I mean I don't
think Edna has really had a an
opportunity to fully uh vet this thing
we do have the three amendments and we
appreciate having them but I've heard
nothing that makes me think that you've
had adequate time to go through the
whole thing so I I'll be voting with due
respect against the motion
further comments from members of the
division
well I had the opportunity along with
representative Sweeney to have some
discussions this morning with the
governor and I brought this specific
issue up and I explained my concern that
the boards and other agencies that are
embedded in the pl
POI I can't even say it now oplc
um that nobody was consulted
and he said that's correct he worked
with the executive director and himself
and his staff in the whole intent of not
involving people is to get their
attention and I told him he had
certainly gotten their attention
and that I also went on to say I thought
it should be more thoroughly reviewed by
the Edna committee and he said you can
certainly tell your group that it was my
intention to put it out there so
um anyway at that and
with the regret representative Griffin I
can't support your motion either
if there are any further questions there
is a motion before us to accept
Amendment one two three four and well
not three so one two four one two four
that was offered by uh representative
Griffin signal further discussion
the clerical please call the rule okay
uh representative McGuire no
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney no representative
Campbell's no representative grassy no
representative Hewitt no
Clark vert's votes no chair Leachman no
okay so it is
seven to one no
so the motion to adopt oplc amendments
one two and four is defeated the chair
would look forward to another motion I
believe representative McGuire has a
motion yes I'll move um Amendment 11 26
h
and once everyone has a copy
representative Maguire if you could
speak to your promotion yes
yes
all right so it this bill this this
amendment
line one deletes this entire section
okay and then the rest of the the rest
of the pages add back certain parts with
on occasion changes but but generally
speaking no
I just want to make sure that we're all
clear so I
um so you're deleting the entire section
in HB 2 of the oplc and you're going to
be working to reinsert stuff from
655 or no 650 6.55 explain how it
interweaves or maybe you will with 655.
it's not 6.55 no but this
um I admit I worked on this and most of
these are are items that are
independent of 655 there is for example
the movement of a number of boards from
the Secretary of State to the oplc
and there's some cleanup we move the
assessing
certification board and some of the
language needed last year when some of
the language new cleanup that was
included in house bill 2. and it appears
to appears to be reasonable
okay representative groda I see you've
moved the mic well I haven't looked at
this but
I'm I'm looking at it from the back to
the front and
um
it repeals so like on page 21 I'm
looking at this very quickly page 21
line 22 thank you ah here we go
so surely
um we can you know things like these are
things I would have addressed if we had
just repealed everything
and not I had this kind of like
piecemeal kind of thing
I can certainly
um
let's I'm looking at this page that we
just handed to me
things like
athlete agents
Auctioneers
boxing and wrestling
um
I don't want to interrupt you
representing quota but I thought maybe
representative McGuire could finish with
his oh I apologize I apologize
right so so there are
some there are two or three or four
repeals straight repeals still in this
all right but the ones you were
mentioning boxing etc those are not
repeals those are movements from
Secretary of State to
um oplc yes right and then those
arrangements appear
appear to be well within the governor's
suggestion that we know the uh secretary
of state has not objected to that yeah
he testified before us he accepted the
three removals exactly and the oplc is
willing to take them on the there are
almost no changes in the statutes that
are being moved over to the oplc
those transfers don't delete any
licenses
they just transfer the administrative
attachment of those boards
all right representative Dia McGuire you
like to continue so so in terms of the
actual removal of licenses on people
there are I believe three left in this
the athlete agents of which there's a
very tiny number I don't think there's
anyways the athlete agents the Hawkers
and Peddlers and the itinerant vendors
two of those are currently
um
attached to the Secretary of State so
instead of just moving them to the oplc
we just decided there's such a small
thing to to let them go now
representative grassy brought up reasons
why maybe we shouldn't do that and if so
those sections could easily be deleted
from this but they are in it and I
believe that's the only those are the
only license
eliminations in this section
most of what's here
is in the nature of cleanup for example
um and and I'd like these others to
correct me if I'm wrong but let's turn
to page 17 just as an example
okay and look at section 58.
yes okay State licensed or certified
real estate appraisers real estate
appraiser board so this is a board that
already in law
um
well no this is a board which is now in
the Secretary of State's office right
and it's being moved it's in the dra
we partially moved it from the dra last
year the the real estate appraisers and
the assessing cert and the assessors
were in the dra we moved them last year
but it appears that we didn't
we weren't as thorough as we would have
liked and we need some cleanup that's
the uh the first section on the
certification board and this on the uh
real estate appraisers are our cleanup
it does not delete any licenses or
change any requirements to be an
assessor or a real estate appraiser
right but one thing it does do and and
this is where we defaulted to the
governor in several cases notice it
makes the board on line 19 five members
instead of seven
so the governor is the person who's
appointing these people has trouble
finding them
Etc and so it deletes the banking
executive director and makes it one
member of the public instead of two
um
but still the same three real estate
appraisers yeah the same license Etc now
look on page 18 this is another thing
that there's a lot of changes similar to
this on line two
so this says the board shall meet at
least once each calendar Corridor
um and and you must have four members of
the board present you know Quorum kind
of thing so a lot of
these smaller less active boards have
trouble meeting that often that's
specified in law of trouble finding
quorums and things like that so there's
a number of places in this bill where
these kind of requirements to meet at a
certain you know we have one board they
haven't met since 2019 for example you
know so
and they're required by law to meet
every quarter or something you know so
we're taking away some of those kind of
requirements
and that's what that's what's going on
here
so these are really in my mind are just
sensible cleanup type of things with the
possible exception of the four of those
three licenses that are being eliminated
I'd like to mention that there is a
deletion of the board of Allied health
professionals that is a composite board
each individual profession involved
has an Advisory Board and
the governor's suggestion is to
eliminate the
the combined board
and let the advisory boards talk
directly to the oplc
so it eliminates one layer of
bureaucracy it does not eliminate any
licenses it doesn't change the
requirements for any licenses
and so there's a
a few cases where responsibilities that
were on the board of Allied Health are
now flowed down to the discrete boards
the genetic counselors have a few words
and so do the uh
uh Recreation therapist I think it is
yeah
so I just want to make comment because
the board wasn't consulted I think that
we should discuss this with them and
also the Ally the professional Allied
Health Board is the board that does
comes Justified before our committee so
we don't want to chop off somebody who's
willing to give us feedback right
um and
I'm looking at this in this part where
the electrician the electrician part
which is not you know this eliminates
the um uh the inspectors will now be in
charge will be will be the
responsibility of the inspectors will
now be in in the under the direction of
oplc as opposed to the board and that's
not really a cleanup in my mind that's a
change I don't have an issue with the
military experience but you know it's
sort of
um
not that there was a significant amount
of work to do this but some of this
stuff is like easy for us to put
together rather than hashing this out
I feel like I'm deboning a chicken
that's already been eaten you know what
I mean isn't that terrible analogy but
that's the only thing I can think of at
the particular minute
could you point to the section and page
I'm talking about
um on this amendment on this piece of
paper here it's a one page 126 sections
353 to 356.
okay
so in the big document which is the one
that I
I haven't this little document I haven't
seen before
no I was looking for it in the McGuire
Amendment but he's oh okay I'm searched
on the bottom
so um
right online thank you online 33.
so instead of having the inspectors
being under the power of the board
they're now under the power of oplc
and
this is you know a change that hasn't
really been discussed with the board of
electricians and I think that this is
something that electrical inspectors are
rather important and it's not that we
don't have expertise in that but what is
that what are the implications of that
and what are the you know when we send
in someone to do the work to do the
overseeing we really I would want to
have input from the electricians on this
kind of a change
representative Carol McGuire any
thoughts on that the electrical
um we've already said that the oplc has
an office of INSP the inspectors work
for the oplc
and their
uh they are required to be licensed
electricians not we don't see that here
but they are required to be licensed
electricians and
meet other qualifications like
being able to travel around and so forth
but the uh this just this just says that
the oplc is their employer
I guess I'm a picky person when it comes
to words
because empower
is not employed
representative grass yeah this
electrician section I was digging
through looking for it I mean there's
just so much here and I finally found it
when you started talking about it as
well something that was someone
approached me in the hallway as well
they have significant concerns about
this the electrician section I mean for
the most part here I'm I don't have a
lot of problems a lot of it when
representative Maguire originally
presented this amendment I thought this
was a good idea but as you know as we
get into the the detail of nitty-gritty
here we're finding little things which
could come back to bite us you know it's
the same thing I said with the Hawkers
and Peddler's license you know you can
get rid of it I'm not going to oppose
that but I'll tell you the unintended
consequences may be worse than what
you're looking for
um and uh but you know this is one that
I think maybe if we wanted to take one
out and hold it this needs I think it
needs a little more research here
because there were some things that were
presented to me through their their
lobbyist that that concerned me as far
as supervision of electricians are
concerned and how this could impact
electricians overall and
um you know it may end up that we do
nothing we not change this but this is a
lot to try to you know to try to take in
in an hour
so I'm going to suggest that instead of
jumping from you know page seven into 17
we'll just start right at the beginning
there are a lot of things that I've
already scanned through I don't see a
problem with but I think if
representative McGuire is start on page
one like with the assessing
section which I was looking at over
didn't seem problematic but just go
through perhaps as rapidly as you could
shall we uh defer to the other
representative McGuire perhaps thank you
for for this kind of detail
yeah the assessing the successing
certified certification board is
currently in in with the dra
all right last year we passed a bill to
separate the assessing certification
board which certifies assessors from the
assessing Standards Board which sets up
the requirements for
um
four assessors including dra assessors
and this
is
as I said it's a bit of cleanup we want
to move the assessing certification
board which licenses individual
assessors
to the oplc
the assessing Standards Board is still
associated with the dra because that's
they do the equalization manual they and
various other things that the dra is
intimately involved in
all right moving right along and
I'm listening okay and this is a uh
auctioneers the auctioneers are moving
applications just repealed okay wait
wait wait wait no no but I I've asked
these agents I saw a number down here
online page two line five repeal athlete
I just process wise so if we're let's
just say all right are we okay with
these sections regarding the assessing
certification board so that would take
us from one to
what one through four section four right
no one sections one through four okay so
and I'm just going to take notes and
then we don't have to go back
okay sections one two four we're okay
all right all right so now we're on six
five five five five is a one-line repeal
of the
registration of athlete agents
okay
good
so now we're to Auctioneer line six
transfers the State Board of auctioneers
from the Secretary of State's office to
the oplc
with the consent of both parties
it doesn't change any of the
requirements for an auctioneer
it ensures their current rules remain in
effect unless changed
and we heard from the secretary of state
that he is fine and that goes that's
through and 12 uh through set through
11.
everybody okay with that
okay
12 is the deletion of the
Allied Health
board
while maintaining the governing Boards
of the individual ones
so Mr chair
um
I actually sought the input of the
national I mean the New Hampshire
Hospital Association and I see Paula is
back there
I my understanding from the in do you
have an issue with the you do not
oh I don't know
yeah the the at the moment there is a
governing board where the
the governing Boards of the individual
professions get together as the board of
Allied Health
and this eliminates that extra layer of
bureaucracy
it doesn't change doesn't delete any
licenses doesn't change any of their
requirements for any of the professions
it maintains the separate governing
boards for each profession
so thank you so let's ask representative
groda is she okay not so okay what do
you think well
it's fun okay okay I'll go let's go and
see how we do with the others yeah going
on with the Allied Health it they uh
each governing board has
um rulemaking Authority criminal record
checks that's mostly just language
cleanup there on the recreational
therapist
[Music]
um
conditions imposed yeah that's it simply
says that what the what the uh
license
conditions are
for discipline
it deletes a reference to the board of
um
Allied Health
Mr chair well just while representative
grottis thinking about Allied Health
uh Paula do you could you give us your
view on why you think it's all right if
the Allied Health Board no longer exists
I'll just be a second actually I'm just
going to
Hospital Association thank you I it's
because of what representative McGuire
said it is an extra layer is the way we
we agree with her that it's an extra
layer and it does not affect the
individual board's um Effectiveness um
so it it removes that extra layer of
redundancy I guess right
why was it created in the first place
question uh because yeah I I don't
recall it was because the individual
professions didn't have enough members
to justify a board of the structure of
say the Board of Nursing
and so they were grouped together into
this
um
you know the the to make it more
convenient more more efficient
because there wasn't an oplc the
the board of of Allied Health did the
things that the oplc is now taking over
such as administrative duties processing
the license and so forth
I have a question about this so if we
I'm looking at page five
line 27 repealing of disciplinary
history but there's is there any who is
who would maintain the disciplinary
Authority within would it stay within
the boards
yes okay and the instead of the Allied
Health Board being responsible for
keeping the records the oplc is
responsible for keeping the records
that's in 655. okay so I'll yield on
that
thank you
17 is the boxing and wrestling
Commission
you know it says could she could she
reference page and line number I did
find that one but I had troubles finding
the last one okay on page six line six
section 17.
transfer first the boxing and wrestling
commission from the
well at the moment it's untethered last
year we repealed its connection to the
Secretary of State and didn't actually
attach it anywhere else
so this attaches it to the to the oplc
with
um
almost no changes except that the except
the fee issues
it's uh
representative Dan McGuire yeah notice
on line 12 there the governor is
actually making the board bigger not
smaller it's making it five members
instead of three for some reason
board is busier than he thought and they
are all um
it's also a very profitable board for
some reason and the
you'll notice that the
um the fees do not go to the oplc except
a five percent
as specified in a different RSA all the
other fees go to the go to the general
fund
well I was just going to say I think
it's because mixed martial arts has
become so popular I think that's what's
going on that's mixed martial arts are
definitely part of the boxing and
wrestling Commission
correct and starting on page 7 26
section 26 starts with the electricians
we're at the bottom of page seven line
27 starts section 26 which is
electricians it defines a journeyman
electrician and says that they're
employed by a master electrician
which is the normal
normal course of uh of things
any comments members some electricians
it looks okay representing grota you
mean electricians as a whole
as far as this section oh that's fine
I'm sorry yeah
which is on page eight line eighteen
it's actually okay 26 to 29. I mean
representative grassy do you have
anything to add on that or no okay
you're all right yeah okay
30 genetic counseling section 30 is the
genetic counselors they the genetic
counselors were added to the Allied
Health Board
for no particular reason as far as I can
tell except there were only a few of
them at the time
so this just adds in the uh changes this
is your editorial comments about
provisional licenses and conditional
licenses which are already in statute
um
privilege country yeah okay it maintains
the
uh
privileged Communications and
[Music]
um
repeals reciprocity because we passed
reciprocity if the
requirements are that are essentially
the same as ours in House Bill 594 just
this week
do I have the last week now
all right everybody
apparently yes all right continuing on
page nine lines 11 and 12 are sections
34 and 35.
um
repeals the Hawker and Peddler's license
in the vendor's license
and
those are currently attached to the
Secretary of State
the only thing I will mention about
those licenses is that last year when we
passed a repeal of those two sections
we were informed that although the
Secretary of State requires a
a criminal record check for this at some
statute they have never
in the 20 odd years I've probably 30 odd
years that that Mr Scanlon has been in
the office rejected a person because of
their criminal record
they get it but they don't reject
anybody from it and they have never in
the history of the office paid out on
the required Bond
so I would say that this license is an
exercise in futility if you have to get
a criminal check that doesn't disqualify
you as far as I can tell and you have to
put up a bond that
you'll get back
when you leave the business
represent camberells thank you Mr chair
uh yes uh representative McGuire uh
representative grassy brought up I I
want to get rid of this like what a
passion to get rid of the Peddler's Hawk
but I have a concern uh the
representative grassy brought up
yesterday
um my reason for getting rid of it is I
thought if we get rid of it at the state
level this RSA the towns cannot then
require
um Peddler and Hawkers because they
cannot refer to this RSA so no the towns
and cities have a separate statutory
authority to require a license if they
so choose and we they actually have a
pretty extensive list of
things they can demand including
criminal record checks that they
presumably look harder at and
um right I don't know if they put choir
references but they might be able to
okay so have they have full authority to
license people working in their tax okay
so my question then is so having said
that if I were to go to the secretary of
state right now and get a Peddler's
license would it be it's active for like
a year we'll say yeah or I believe it's
free okay would that then
um allow me not to have to get it from
the town
no okay so if that's the case and if the
town has requirements they are in
addition
okay so that being you are working from
town to town you would have to get a
separate license from each town that
requires it right so that being the case
this doesn't protect me from the town so
I would repeal it I'd get rid of it yeah
the larger towns including uh I think is
London London Dairy Dairy
Manchester Salem Etc have specific
licenses for Hawkers and Peddlers in in
their in their within their town I don't
believe Epsom has any such requirements
yeah
section 36 which continues on page nine
repeals the board of manufactured
housing
which is a
which is not a quality board it is
essentially a place for for landlord
tenant disputes between the owners of
the park and the tenants
they have not decided on anything since
2019.
they haven't met in uh
quite a while and they shared
jurisdiction with the attorney general
and the consumer complaints issues so
it's kind of redundant
yeah oh no no that's uh it's not on the
sheets sorry about that it's on the
backside of that paper
I had to had to look into because I've
never heard of it
and the fact that it's inactive is a
good reason why we've never heard of it
it doesn't issue any licenses
it's essentially a
a complaint resolution board
okay Fire Control this this is the
mechanical licensing board which is
plumbers gas Fitters and such like it is
it has been trans it's under the um
um
not the office it's under the fire
marshal
not the oplc it's not being moved
um
I don't think it's big enough
you're taking away the sentence about
the secretary yeah well that's that one
sentence right yeah it's a little clean
up here and there
um
technical laws
it changes the structure of the board a
bit by deleting
um
let's say they do
two two plumbers one which goes from two
to one gas fitter
one hurt heating equipment installer
delete the master plumber who's also a
fuel gas fitter
and then a public member
it deletes the need for regular meetings
Etc
elector chairman
um
no no the uh
no that's uh We've we've we've been
tweaking this section for a while and I
think that I don't have any issue with
these
right on page 11 section 39 is the
pharmacy board
in this case it's decreasing the members
from seven to five
four of whom are pharmacists
oh that's a type at least one of whom is
a full-time Hospital pharmacist it
should be one and not two because there
are relatively few full-time Hospital
pharmacists
um and one public member
so would you like us to make an
amendment to the amendment leave the at
least one there that's that would
that allows you to have two if you
happen to get two volunteers but
uh mandating to appears to disqualify
the regular pharmacists right so Melissa
is that all right the page 11 line seven
unchanged
and on the inspections it gives the
board
Authority for the standards for
inspection which are technical what they
what the inspector should look for what
the criteria are and not necessarily the
procedures which are
um
the standards are more important and
that's exactly what the board has the
expertise in
the deletions are
uh
consult are part of the consolidation of
disciplinary hearings and so forth
um
under the oplc that's
Inspection Services the oplc will
provide Inspection Services to the other
boards that have drugs
and the board inspection shall be
provided by pharmacists or pharmacy
technicians licensed by the Board of
Pharmacy who are training and experience
regarding Pharmacy statutes and rules
which sounds like exactly what who you'd
want to be doing that
[Music]
um
all right most of the rest is just
changing board to under the
qualifications changing board to office
no change in the in the actual
requirements for a pharmacist
um
or their inspections or whatever
all the way through the impaired
pharmacist program
um
there's
honesty
I look those it's it's pretty long and
it looks like it's all
pretty minor
edit it's looks like to me
right on page 16 line 32
um
physical therapy this
adds to the powers and duties of the
board
be because which had previously been an
under Allied Health
this uh puts it at the more appropriate
level of the governing board
and uh
except for fees the rest of it is
um
the responsibilities of the governing
board of physical therapy
all right that's true 57 yeah
on page 17 line 14 it starts with the
real estate appraisers
and
and that that I think is part of the
move of the assessing Sussex
57 and yeah they
those are all covered by by sections of
the statute with the oplc like the UN
unlawful practice
it's it's the same for everybody
you say about the uh we'll be prayer
to be peeled yeah
that's I believe the Privacy unlawful
and I'm sure unlawful practice and
reporting violations are in 655 for the
oplc okay okay
the rest of the real estate appraisers
looks
right that takes us to the end
and uh
real estate appraisers yeah the same
thing they're they're moving all right
and then line on page 22 line 26 section
72 says we'll refund your fees
all right representative Carol McGuire
thank you so much for the percentage
I know you've done a lot of work I
really appreciate we all do appreciate
the efforts
uh this was very helpful Melissa hi
thank you
um I was just going through the
amendment comparing it to our notes and
there is one section that's missing that
looks like it should be in the amendment
which is bondsman
oh that's right that was Secretary of
State too I think that's on this sheet
right it's on the sheet but it's not in
the event
made with that thanks for catching that
if we want to look at it it's page 200
of house bill 2.
representative
grassy if I may
um representative McGuire uh did you on
page 11 line seven did you say that
leave the at least one in there on line
seven instead of two
so that would be the only yes at least
one Hospital pharmacist okay so we'd
leave that in instead of changing it to
two who shall be full-time sorry
no Melissa got it all so
the only concern that I have is the
electrician part
I'm still concerned about that part I
want to Circle back to electricians
folks represent grassy yeah I'm just
trying to recall the discussion I had
with the lobbyist who was outside and he
said the concern he had was to deal with
major corporations who have their own
electrical firms inside the company in
that a lot of times you have one
electrician who's a master electrician
and then the other electricians who work
for them are not necessarily licensed
electricians and he said that some
changes in here could impact them well
their licensed electricians are just not
licensed Master electricians right so
they were just concerned that the person
that would be super supervising all that
would be so someone that would be chosen
by oplc as a course as opposed to the
electrical War electricians board which
is why that chant that's how that change
change that time okay you're talking
about these
large organizations that have a large
number of
journeyman electricians which are
licensed but
they're not joining them in electricians
technically they've actually work for
the company so I guess they could be
called they are not licensed Journeymen
electricians then they can't do a great
they can't legally do a great many
things that I would presume they would
wanted to do that's that's correct and
we have the gentleman here I guess and I
would say that that's
I don't think this makes it any worse
but that is a
possibly this line 30 on page seven we
have the gentleman here okay coming up
I think that's a what's this what page
you're on page seven page seven line
Thirty okay yeah
and if you could please state your name
for the record thank you uh Simon
Thompson I'm a lobbyist machine Finney
Capital group and the client that I was
talking to the representatives for is
the electrical contractor Business
Association and it's specific to the
current Amendment we're looking at page
8 line 14.
um RSA 319-c colon 10 relative to
electrician corporations and
Partnerships
and it's it is talked about prior and
we're removing and what this amendment
is doing is removing it my client was
concerned with this aspect of it
um I talked with executive director
Courtney uh in the hallway uh a few
minutes ago and um basically the board
of electricians according to director
Courtney
um is has a wording it says May
instead of Xiao so director Courtney
feels like that's a voluntary license
and something that she's not supportive
of
um so I think there's some uh
miscommunication between who I've been
speaking with in the board so I'd like
to sort that out but I think I don't
think that's worth yes and I'd like to
mention that
this um this amendment on line 30
deletes that exemption and it simply
maintains a requirement that a
journeyman electrician shall be employed
by a master electrician
so whether it's an individual or a
business there's a master electrician at
the head and in fact my understanding is
the only reason you need
a master's license is to be able to
be the head of the business
the the technical abilities of the
Journeymen are pretty much the same
are you all set represented thank you
thank you very much
representative Hewitt
the that same section
on page
on page seven line Thirty this is
employed by a master electrician except
as provided in RSA 310 C10 what's that
we just we just went through it this
deletes that exception which would allow
which deals with businesses
you'll notice that that accept is
provided is crossed out
right but maybe the business would like
that exception so they don't have to
have a master to employ a journeyman is
that is that the idea I know this the
let me look up the section so we can I'm
I'm pretty sure that that the there
there is no intention to have a
journeyman electrician working for
himself because that is just not you
know
this says that you shall be employed by
a master electrician period
and the exemptions or whatever that
would whatever Clauses were in
319 C10 are no longer applicable
it's so representative Dan Maguire would
still be allowed to put your light bulb
in
it is allowed to to change your own
light bulb in your own business
in your own home
provided of course it's a one it's a
single family yes
representative Sweeney has a question or
a comment
well I could read you this particular
section but it it basically says the
board can issue a license to
corporations and Partnerships engaged in
business of electrical installation as
long as they have someone in their
officers or employees who is a master
electrician
so so this is a license for
companies basically
um and what section is that
I'm reading 310c 31 319 C colon 10 which
is a section that's being removed
so basically it sounds like they no
longer need to license
the company they they still would
license the the Masters and the
journeyman and so on so this it you know
it's a semi-substantive change
okay the pleasure of the division with
the electricals end of things
we okay
foreign
believe me we talked to the electricians
regularly and they have not expressed uh
any concern about this they're they're
okay
yeah they were concerned about making
sure the inspectors were qualified which
I believe is something that we
have dealt with in in 655 and if we need
to beef up the requirements in the
future we'll do so but I we we have
taken that complaint very seriously for
that concern
thank you uh representative Sweeney
please thank you Mr chairman I I want to
thank representative McGuire
representative McGuire representative
Brody Ena everyone for for the effort
they have put into this I have been
proud of my ability on division one to
be able to read the room
um in reading the room I feel I will be
uh in the minority or by myself in
voting no on this amendment only because
I I think I might be one of the few uh
supporting the governor's initial
proposal from hb2
chairman Legion you and I had coffee
with him this morning along with other
members from Finance he talked about
opening up the white board for Licensing
in the state allowing the free market to
work as the free market does I have no
doubt that the Restorations uh the the
vetting from Edna for the Restorations
that this amendment presents after
deleting the governor's proposal uh will
do go Great Lengths to reform Licensing
in the state and how our state manages
ourselves and our economy with the free
market however as a as a purist and as
they uh
self-declaring that this is not going to
cost my vote on the overall budget but I
will just be able to uh
advocate for the original submission of
hb2 while we vote on this amendment and
still then support hp2 as a whole uh I
want to thank the governor for starting
this conversation I know the emails the
phone calls it's been a conversation
that people have been trying to have in
the state for years uh and this process
really brought it up to the the fold and
brought it up to everyone's attention uh
when the guy with the veto prin starts a
conversation people start to listen uh
and I want to continue to Champion for
future licensing reforms uh originally
represent when I thought it was just
going to amend the bill to delete all
the sections and then vote more back in
when it was separate I was going to vote
no to delete the sections and then vote
Yes to bring some back in but since it's
all tied in I'm not voting no because I
I don't want these sections in the
budget I'm voting no because I'm only
going to get a little bit of the slice
of cake that I want in my sense of the
room is that that I can take that vote
without risking it
um but I do I just wanted to say that
I'm glad we got through the review
without having to debate any individual
portion of it because I would have felt
as if I was negotiating in bad faith on
an amendment that I wouldn't ultimately
be supporting so I appreciate the
conversation we just had on on each
section line by line I just wanted to
for the record and for everybody
watching I get I didn't wear my tie
today so I guess I can't be pulled by
the neck for being so bold anybody that
wants to complain to me about licensing
feel free to keep emailing and calling
me that's fine uh because I intend to
stick around for a bit and continue to
fight for these reforms but I just want
to let that air out thank you very much
you're a very valued member of our
exhibition as all members are
representative Griffin
sat here for the last hour
on Thursday
I'm sorry I sat here for the last hour
and I'm very very impressed
with the work that went into this
document
and with both representative Maguire's
efforts in it
uh
I probably too will join representative
Sweeney but some of the rain some of the
same reasons
but my concern is we're doing the work
of a policy committee
and we are a finance committee
and in the last hour of discussion I
haven't heard
one word that related to class
savings
or anything else and I love the document
I hope it passes but
I I am going to vote against it
any further questions representative
Kimbrell's thank you Mr chair I respect
representative Griffin's position but
someone has to be the adult in the room
and I think we were the adults so we're
going to push this forward finally and I
will be voting for it
thank you representative Kimbrell's
seeing no further questions we will be
voting on The mcgui did we have a second
to your motion we must I think a second
okay
yeah but so the motion has been made by
representative McGuire and seconded by
representative Abel to adopt Amendment
2023-1126 h
when the clerk is this one with one
small change that Melissa's gotten from
go from two yeah
uh advancement the bondsman and the
uh going back to uh at least one
all right being seeing no further
questions and the clerk is ready please
call the roll okay uh representative Dan
Maguire yes representative Griffin no
representative Sweeney no representative
cambrell's yes
uh representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes Clark Brooks
yes representative Leachman yes
do you want to vote Carol McGuire oh
she's already left
she said alone
all right the uh Amendment passes uh six
to two and it will have just a couple of
changes regarding bondsman and there was
a change in one of the board numbers
thank you
thanks very much members we have just a
very few things left Mr Hoffman Melissa
you did hand out our status sheet
earlier today and I didn't see too many
areas that weren't grayed out but did we
also have commissioner arlinghaus is
commissioner Goulet are in the hallway
okay the follow-up on the Erp
conversation yeah okay
so we'll take a five minute break
until three o'clock
yeah welcome to my world
Find The Substitute you know
all right we'll uh get going represent
uh we have two representatives from our
state government here doit commissioner
and the d e d a s d a s Department of
administrative Services a the a for the
top of the Heap so uh Charlie and
I and I believe you're here because
there was a concern raised about
competitive bidding and so forth for
I think we're here at your invitation
yes
um we're here because anytime you would
like to see us we're happy to come by uh
hopefully I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commission of administrative Services
I'm Dennis Goulet commissioner for the
Department of Information Technology and
if we run into trouble Sherry Rockburn
is behind us and at some point she
starts waving her arms wildly because of
something I said I hope you'll tell me
well she's really The A Team you can
tell us the truth but yes exactly
and so I shared with you my concern that
was raised about the new system and the
costs and the bidding maybe you could
explain that for us I I I'm going to
start and uh
what I want the committee to know is
that
we're not doing this half
heartedly I almost said I was trying to
come up with something
um we're not doing this half-heartedly
and this is something we've been doing
our due diligence on for a long time and
have worked very closely with uh with
the commissioner and with and with the
governor's office to do what we're doing
and there's a there's a way state
procurements are done and and obviously
I would have a concern if the if the
only thing you ever put in the state
budget in the last decade about
procurement and having to go to fiscal
was not Medicaid not mmis not HHS
contracts not correction contracts not
safety contracts not Transportation
contracts or labor contracts or banking
contracts but merely one procurement
that I was doing to single me out as a
scoff law and a nerdy will and I hope to
convince you that I am not scoffing at
the law or
that I do well more often than Nair
um so
we we have a computer system and we've
talked to you about what the Erp is and
and how it is and we looked at what we
do I've talked to the committee about
how we really do have three choices one
is to do nothing which
it's not a choice I understand
um so to keep you on your leash
um and to uh to reprocure entirely into
a whole new system or to upgrade the
system that we have and that a lot of
the reason that we we chose to upgrade
the system we have is is the is the cost
and we can do uh reasonable cost
estimates without doing an RFP you can
figure out what things cost by order of
magnitude what we relied on for doing
that is not me sort of guesstimating and
Googling but the expert advice of people
like doit and and we discussed it in
intensely with the with the governor and
we do believe there's a significant cost
there are two pieces right the one is
um
the risk to the state of overturning the
system and going forward it's a risk
that if the cost is the same we would we
would uh bear but uh the the
exponentialness of the price difference
is what led us to decide to do an
upgrade we happen to know based on
technological research that to go from
an on-premise info product to the next
iteration which is a cloud-based infor
product they've done an analysis of a
technical analysis which I doubt I can
explain but about the fit between the
two systems and how much of a change
management it is and it's relatively
modest in terms of upgrades and so
that's one reason we did this but we we
believe and I want Dennis to talk about
this a little bit if I can we believe
that there's an order of magnitude on
cost and and the reason we're doing this
is because not because we suspect that
there's similar costs but because we
know there's an enormous difference
between the two items
so thanks Charlie
um so there you might ask well why is
there a difference in cost and you know
I've I've heard some opinions stated
that that doing this action with infor
is is equivalent to reprocuring the
system which it is not and I'll explain
that a little bit in more detail
throughout my career I've seen vendors
say hey we've got this new this shiny
new product product and we want you to
move to it
and it's going to you know and and since
it's ours it'll be easy but if it's a
completely different product then then I
would always say oh time to re-procure
in other words maybe they went out and
acquired it or they developed an
in-house and it's new
so
um
so then that is oh yeah that's
re-procurement time because you know
that the effort's going to be just as
great to use your incumbents so new
solution as it would be to implement
somebody else's Solution that's not the
case here the solution
um that infor has in the cloud was
evolved directly from the solution we're
running today in New Hampshire in our
data center over at 27 Hazen so when you
look at the structure of the data and
and the things that that are in that in
that system they're very very similar
from the old to news and and the effort
to get from old to new is really around
looking at how we implemented
the system as it runs today and what's
the best way to implement it with in
terms of the vision going forward within
four versus a you know a huge technical
effort of transition so it really isn't
you know a a complete new system is an
apple moving to the infor cloud Suite is
an orange it's just not the same thing
and I think that explains why we feel
that there's such a significant Charlie
used orders of magnitude that's the term
I I like to use as well
um it's uh we we feel that there is an
orders of magnitude difference
additionally there's a logistic there's
logistical challenges associated with
this that are timing related which I can
go into Charlie or or you can go into
um
timing is such that
we can pretty rapidly move into this
Cloud suite and de-risk the situation we
have now with respect to end of life for
our existing system
and it's one of the things we've looked
at for multiple systems across the state
that have chosen to go with the
incumbent recently
versus you know a full a full
re-implementation time to get from point
A to point B
um
in terms of adding the value that's
there so we have the ability to do this
I think
very quickly compared to what it would
take to do a full re-procurement and
considerably less money so
uh I don't know if you have any more
problems no I think that's I I mean most
I won't answer questions the committee
has but just to give you a sense of what
we're doing and why
does the committee have questions
representative cameras thank you Mr
chair do you feel that your current Erp
system is good enough and solid enough
to carry you into the future after you
do the upgrade of the the and how many
years do you think it would take well I
I would I mean it'll last as long as any
Erp system would you know in the sense
of you know I don't think that uh you
know oracle will work taking our epic or
you know pick something that that sap
that that something would last a lot
longer than others
um
do we have to do something yes is the
product that we have a pathetic inferior
product no it's I mean frankly at the
end of the day
I don't want I'll be accused of slander
here but um an Erp system is an Erp
system they have advantages and
disadvantages and the one we have is
fine and it as Dennis said to me once
everybody hates their Erp right and it's
not because of
that it's very Erp it's because
everybody hates the computer and having
to do things that way but no it's a it's
a perfectly reasonable system and if if
yeah and that was my point that I was
getting at it because of course the big
players that are known are Oracle sap
and I just wanted to make sure that you
weren't going with some Rinky Dink Erp
company that is on its last legs and and
is not going to be able to take you
forward into the future you know no I'll
I'll mention that if you if you look and
this is something you actually could
Google right if you look at you know the
top erps you know who would you
um I think one of your first Google hits
would be who are the top six erps in the
country and this is one of them they're
very well capitalized it's a company
that
when we bought a system 10 14 ish years
ago let's call it 0607 the company we
bought at the time was called Lawson
and uh infor is a much larger company
that has bought I think they probably
were called
agilysis or something like that at the
beginning I don't know what they were
called but um they bought a lot of other
companies and and so it's one of these
it's so it's one of the major players
it's not you know if you said to me if
you go to bed who's going to Bid And so
they're one of the people who would bet
they're they're real
the strategy that we're pursuing also
solves a fairly large problem for the
state particularly for for a part of my
department and a big part of Charlie's
in that it it'll Shield us largely
Shield us from some of the system life
cycle stuff that we've been dealing with
and we've been spending time and effort
now any cloud-based solution would
generally do that but we we would get a
pretty large benefit from um
from moving to Cloud Suite we we would
get a similar benefit
from any Cloud product with more effort
um the the other thing is is that you
know over a period of years even the
just the eight years I've been here you
know seeing that you know it's one thing
for a company to say we're going to
invest and we're going to make the
product better
it's another thing to actually have it
happen in front of you which I've
observed you know where the they said
all right well we're going to do these
things to make it but to improve on it
and they actually are executing on that
you know so as Charlie said there it's
hard you know I've been on the other
side in the industry when you acquire
products to integrate them into your
core products that's really difficult to
do and and it's something you have to
increment over time and infor has been
working on that
um some of the major players in the
market have have had to do the same
thing the big players they've been
integrating stuff over the years and
some of them are well done and some
aren't and then there's new players that
have started from scratch which don't
don't have that challenge per se so so I
think that you know that's certainly a
point of evidence that
um again on the you know we didn't just
make this up we thought about it uh
point that Charlie made
other questions from the committee no uh
let me ask uh what's the downside of
going out to a bid and finding out that
this is twice as cheap as something else
there there are there are actually two
two pieces of that right the the first
is time that it it's it's months and it
puts us it would probably set us back uh
round numbers six months
um and uh gets us closer to running out
of the arpa money there's a time limit
to spending the Europa money and and if
I mean if we're honest with ourselves
this is New Hampshire we would not be
able to upgrade our system the way we
typically have budget pressures
um except in a year like this one and
when there was arpa money available I
mean it's just the fact of life
um the second piece is that one of the
I think we get better pricing by not if
if we've decided
so procurement broadly writ right you
you at some point at the end of a
contract you look at it do I want to
renew the contract do I want an
amendment to extend if I have extension
years left on my contract and what am I
getting out of that because it's a
benefit to the company right I'm going
to call up you know Fred's garage and
say
if we don't go out to bid what kind of
pricing are you going to get me as
opposed to I go out to bed Fred's going
to give me a better price because he
doesn't have to go out to bed and and I
think that that
I think if we did an RFP we would end up
within four again because the change
management is so dramatically less
because of because the product we're
moving from is in for two in four when
one imagines that it's going to be a
little easier for them but at a
different price there's a I mean I think
we have a
um a price break because we're not uh
doing that and and we certainly expect
that that's the case
thank you so are there are you gonna
because this is cloud-based are you
gonna have to upgrade your internet
services and pay more to Comcast or
whoever because of that
we we did that
um
before the great DS diaspora uh kova
diaspora so we're sitting pretty on
internet
um oh what what does change though is
sometimes and we may want to consider
that
um for some of our applications I'll
I'll just use um CAD RMS for Department
of Safety A computer-aid dispatch
records management system we provisioned
a circuit to Amazon web services for
safety so that they wouldn't be
contending with other traffic so it
wasn't so much of a total bandwidth
thing it was a purity of of mission
thing on the network so we would
consider that we we will probably do
something like that with liquor as well
when at the appropriate time for their
cloud-based system as well
is our Microsoft product is currently
uh uh internet based as opposed to on my
computer well the the Microsoft products
that we're all running now in all
branches and constitutional offices is
Microsoft 365 which is sitting in some
data center somewhere in Virginia and we
don't think much about it and we did not
provision extra bandwidth for that
although what we did find was that in
some agencies or some locations where
they had a you know they had a really
small
a connection back to the Mothership the
mothership being 27 Hayes and we did
tweak that a little bit to help them
with their performance and Charlie might
have been in that category or maybe in
that category but I'm not sure so for
example when we're we're doing
renovations on the annex right now or
about two and it includes wires and a
bunch of other stuff that are technical
um and I am told reliably that our wires
will improve and that I will see
um faster results when I'm using Excel
as well whenever we do work in a
building we pull stuff out of the wall
and try to replace it with a wider thing
that's not technically accurate well
another another project that's ongoing
is we are replacing almost the entire
executive branch Network
which was funded with
with arpa money's a while back and we're
well into the implementation of that in
fact all of liquor is done that wasn't
funded with arpa liquor funded on liquor
operations but but the same I it's the
basically the same project with
different funding sources so that's
that's ongoing Charlie's we're trying to
coordinate with the renovations and
putting the new gear and why I think
there's some wires too I'm not sure but
something but but it uh but your
question sir is is the good one in that
it the going to the cloud does change
how you think about your networking and
the importance of your network internet
pipes and
um in this budget we've seen a lot of
spending for it and not just this one
but liquor
agriculture I think we just approved
something for Human Rights Commission or
something are we trying to ask you for
too much here trying to too many
upgrades all at once or are we going to
be comfortable
um well we're we're doing a lot
um a lot more than we ever had and I and
if you'd have asked my staff if you know
four years ago if this was possible um I
think they would have said no uh one of
the things that changed all around the
country in state governments during
covid was we we moved a lot faster and
we thought it was just going to be a
temporary thing but it isn't it's
changed the pace of how we operate and
and my expectations of
pace have have adjusted and and so so my
expectation is that we will
um we need to fund things properly in
other words if we don't have enough
staff State staff to get something done
during the good times then we got to
make sure that we augment it a little
bit to make sure that it happens which
is a part of what Charlie's team has
considered in his proposal and uh so I'm
I'm comfortable like that the human
rights is a great one they've been
struggling for years trying to get
something to happen can we make that
happen
yes
so um I just ask you uh if you find
yourself having to prioritize I think
this committee would appreciate it if
you do dra and liquor first and let the
others
under revenue is King
foreign
thank you very much any other questions
on this topic okay we have an item so I
think we already approved this item but
does anybody want to revisit it no okay
good
um uh from the hospital to Granite Place
purchase is still white here so Charlie
uh was there anything
pending here
um I think on this one we were choosing
that to vote until we found out if we
could use arpa funds I was able to get
in touch with the governor's budget
director this morning and he said
um arpa funds are very limited at this
point and they wouldn't be able to be
allocated for this project all right so
presumably we still need granite place
so therefore
if you want a garage
I don't but anyway
yes it represents thank you so I do see
here uh it says 21 million in fiscal
year 23 so that's surplus funds
currently so
do we have an updated Surplus fund
statement that we're not overspending
this oh yeah
foreign
ER of course
I can just point out something on this
document that may be helpful um I just
want to point out two things on the
document one we just worked with HB 571
so you know that's built in here as a
84.2 million dollar hit which I think
representative McGuire you said would be
an estimated 10 million
so we'll gain back
um about 70 million 74 million on that
so then that negative balance at the
bottom of the page will then flip to
positive and granite place because it
was in the governor's budget is already
factored into this so you don't have to
take a hit on that it's only if you
reduce it will you add back money
all right so do we need a show of hands
that will accept items number 75 and 76
in House Bill 2. unanimous all right
very good
what's next and I'd be excused or yes
thank you for coming unless you know of
any other Das matters that are
pendings
yeah
all right so the next one I see is uh
House Bill 2 section 266.
and yes historic sites I think we did
this one yeah the other day there was a
house built two section that funded that
um and in our work we found there's a an
account in house bill one that we can
just flip the funding on it's more
appropriate to be changed in house bill
one we discussed it with the agency and
they're fine
so we would
eliminate that section instead of
approve it
I see all right so we'll still spend the
same amount of money but it'll be in
house bill one as opposed to House Bill
two that's correct everyone all right
without raise your hands yeah okay good
so we'll do that
Professional Licensing we just did that
but it's a plus let me put a star on
there
you want to reconsider
[Laughter]
um so now we have new food waste add
Contents I thought we already did that
yeah
these amendments in White have been
discussed
but not formally approved
all right so representative evil would
you like to move Amendment 1070
.
so yeah
they took away yourself yeah
yeah
okay
right so representative McGuire you want
to continue they didn't get any
complaints when I came back so I think
I'm going to be doing a good job okay so
representative evil Elizabeth
so we were just going through the things
that hadn't been shaded out and we had
just a few more
things to do so um we have to uh just
approve a bunch of amendments that we've
been talking about so the first one here
is 10 I I move passage of uh Amendment
1070 H which is the embodiment of the um
food waste disposal
discussion in discussion no all right
let's call the request problem
all right
I don't know okay hang on guys thank you
so much I'm still stuck on oplc here
okay
all right 10 70 H all right
um
evil moved and Maguire seconded I think
all right representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrells yes
representative grassy yes
Hewitt here okay evil votes yes
representative leishman yes okay
one two three four five six zero the
amendment passes
or seven I don't count very well that's
why you're on finance oh you know I
didn't I I was so busy riding in grassy
that I I okay
okay so that's the first one so um Mr
Hoffman there's a double question mark
um
moving a position is there any reason
for that yes that was the house bill 2
Section requested by Environmental
Services to transfer a position and
that's another one that as we work
through it we realize we can do that in
house bill one we don't need a house
bill 2 section
okay so shall we do that so we have an
amendment so you're just going to add a
position to House Bill we would make the
swap in house bill one and then delete
this section and that's where that
amendment number would do is delete this
section okay
all right so do we need to see it or are
we happy yeah all in favor yeah all
right go done for that one
um representative leishman new section
relative to Liquor Commission
and so thank you Mr Hoffman okay
thanks Mr Hawk and for finding this
language
this is something that representative
Ober when she was chair of division one
and uh representative
Karen
uh bum burger from North Conway
we have discussed this in the past quite
a bit
on the fistel committee The Liquor
Commission will come in to tell us they
have closed a liquor store and there's
no notice and it's been somewhat uh
problematic to some of us that the
public isn't forewarned of a closure
so as you can see in this language it
would require at least input by the
fiscal committee and the governor and
Council
before a closure happens
oh this was in the budget two years ago
but the Senate took it out
representative McGuire so
um I guess to be fair isn't this wasn't
this a bill that the Commerce Committee
didn't care for this year or well
they've never cared for it but I seem to
recall testifying in the Commerce yeah
and this actually adds the governing
Council so it's a little different
before it was just the fiscal committee
that went to Commerce but this adds a
government Council and the fiscal
committee
that's
thanks okay
so it's moved by representative Griffin
and seconded by representative evil
okay
representative McGuire yes yes
so I'm Sweeney yes
cameras yes
grassy yes
yes chair Leachman yes
thank you
thanks
I really think representative Abel's
name should be on here Mr Hawk and I
know it's always supposed to be the
chair but the efforts that
have gone on it should probably be
representative Ebola
yeah I know
um all right uh so I'd like to move
um Amendment
1063h relative to HB 212. it's been
moved is it second it represents Sweeney
thank you okay
um so this basically just
um does what I explained in finance
yesterday we decided uh not to
appropriate new funds for the pfas fund
but to expand the capability of the
existing fund to use
a limited number of funds for
investigating testing and monitoring for
pfas and the new language is on page 2
line 34 and 35. so it allows them to use
up to 10 of the original appropriation I
think which is 25 million to do some
really really important work that they
need to continue doing
questions for representative evil
seeing none
all right representative McGuire
yes
perfect yes representative Sweeney yes
representative yes
representative grass yes
clerk votes yes chair leashman yes yes
okay thank you
okay seven nothing
so we've taken up the next one is that
right yeah one has already been done Mr
chairman yes I have the amendment that
incorporates
that if you want to pass out oh that'd
be that'd be great this morning thank
you
foreign
well since we've discussed this at some
length and we've already voted and these
include all those minor little changes
Melissa
thank you
so much
would you like to comment on I I assume
this takes care of all the little nooks
that we
took care of this morning this afternoon
so this is the combination on the list
that you have in front of you of
um well it's the HB 436 Amendment but it
was Pearson's Amendment represent
Pearson's Amendment with the IND the
1022 is it the one that you voted on
this morning it's the um representative
Pearson's language it has the uh IND
repeal moving up the repeal and then
restoring
or it's deleted at the section
repeal CST
all right
can you show me the line where it uh
pulled back the CST
um to bring back the CST let me just do
this one if you did it on page 11.
um
line 28
and I'll end 28 through 32
representative Sweeney that should cover
the section where the state will cover
the cost of political subdivisions if
there's a cost of a bill
foreign
Aid on page 12.
thank you
here we go
all right since we've already voted on
this
the amendment 1140 I guess it does have
a new number everybody okay with the
vote we already took on it
form representative evil would like to
formalize well the
the clerk feels like it would probably
be appropriate I'll move
amendment
1148.
seconded by representative Griffin
okay
1148 when the clerk is ready
all right I will I guess representative
hewittism here but that's all right okay
representative
it's not yes okay representative Griffin
yes representative Sweeney yes yes
representative grassy reluctantly yes
uh representative the clerk
clerk both know representative leishman
yes okay
okay so six to one the motion passes I
just think it's cleaner to do it that
way
all right representative McGuire we've
already done this
um or have we not I think we approved
house bill 50 but we haven't actually
moved it
okay so everybody okay moving it into
the budget Melissa says no
sorry if I could just jump in again so
hb50 has been already passed by full
finance and I believe is going to be
heard on the floor
so I believe you wanted this
amended well can we now can we do things
slightly in reverse order in the sense
that I expect it to be tabled so
um after the passive and table that's my
plan
um can we for now accept this amendment
and that way when I say you know if I
know why I should table this that it's
already in the budget
go that way yeah
yeah I think you're fine because the
full finance committee vote is the
committee's report
so that will happen sometime next week
and you'll have
um Friday
if you need to make a change okay I
believe the plan is to for all the
divisions to recess until Friday morning
timing wise it works so you'd rather we
do don't take this vote now
it's up to you either way
okay I just have a question Mr Hoffman I
should know the answer but
if we table something
at this late stage doesn't it take a
super majority to get it off the table
yeah
so I guess I'm just yeah yeah or get a
super majority I'm just concerned if we
put it on the table or we ever get it
off if it's
but he's just
he was just going to roll it into age
yeah what I'm going to say is
um
you know now that we've passed it
I want to put it on the table and we
will put it into house bill to
to give it more chance of being passed
in the long run right because if we just
send it as a bill to the Senate right
they can say no right it doesn't affect
the budget we have no more no more shot
at it sort of all right but if we put it
in House Bill 2 they say no now we can
argue right now we can it's something
that's yes it's kind of a unique way of
doing it but I'm not surprised you have
some UniQue Ideas so we're good
[Laughter]
working out
so what
okay so the rims information management
when the uh
Treasurer asked to have the debt service
line move from treasury to revenue yeah
that supports that project they uh
they initially disagreed and then they
met and came up with a compromise that
would include this uh change we looked
at it the other day but I'll pass it out
[Music]
thanks
all right so
just a new bold language I guess
anyone have any issues with this you
know we did hear from the commissioner
of Revenue and
I guess we'd hoped that they could
afford it without going to the
Governor but
all right seeing any show just to show
our hands is that all right everybody
okay good
thank you Mr Hoffman
right where's that other little sheet
that I saw earlier on my pile yes we do
have a
list of outstanding items from
agency budgets that'll be this page
321.
thank you
so information technology department
funding of additional requests
yep you've uh you've reviewed the budget
have you reviewed their requests and
approved some of them or actually most
of them in this case the only thing is a
uh acceptance of the budget as a whole
okay did we ever hear back there was
safety and Fish and Game yes did we ever
hear back
I checked with the other divisions and
those agencies that are paying for those
did not make the request oh they didn't
okay so since the since the agency
paying
didn't ask for it I don't see any need
to uh
add it here
all right so uh
again this is just uh the budget amounts
as far as the priorities that we put
back do we have a number
Mr Hoffman I
um we don't have a final number we have
a lot of work to do with okay with the
interagency transfers and making sure we
get the data entry correct
all right we all we'll get those numbers
everybody okay with obviously if we
approve their priority requests we have
to fund them
and we did look at the numbers I believe
so
child advocate we did put a few things
there where
Melissa I just grabbed representative
Weiler so he could propose a couple
amendments I'm it's the little window by
grabbing him oh good for hb2 so I didn't
know yeah that's perfect well he's here
representative Weiler has some really
shocking amendments for us
Banks represent Weiland
I would consider them more as
housekeeping
[Laughter]
so one of the things that that irritated
me and it's I will be referring to uh
Amendment 1042h
um
we got the budget on the 15th of
February on time
hb2 I would like to have looked at at
the same time
and it got delivered on April on
February 15th but it got delivered to
OLS
I want to last sat there for two weeks
going through with a fine-tooth Como 237
pages of it to see if referring to see
if it referred to the proper law and to
see if all the grammar was correct it
took two weeks that I would like to have
seen in the brief five or six weeks we
have to do a budget to be able to look
at hb2 during that time as well so what
this amendment does it requires it to be
publicly posted on the department of
administrative services website on the
date of transmittal
so that we can look at it immediately
and if they want to make some nitpicky
little changes to it fine we'll we'll
wait and look at those and see how much
change there was but the basics of it I
don't think will change tremendously and
we need it before us at the same time we
also need before us the revenue
estimates which came two weeks late
we haven't fixed that in this bill we'll
have to fix that internally with the
Ways and Means Committee but this would
at least have it available for us to
look at
and we can probably get if it's on a
website and it's published we would be
able to get published copies to look at
as well so I'm hoping you'll adopt this
it will go in the the
hb2 is is kind of a commentary and it
will go forward as we have done several
times with other things that we thought
ought to be changed in in the budget and
some of them have persisted for years
representative Weiler representative
McGuire has a question for you yeah I'm
wondering if this maybe should be at the
legislative budget assistant website
where all the other budget documents are
collected rather than administrative
services
I'll have to talk to the LBA and see if
they'd have room for it yeah Mr Hoffman
we would most definitely post it we
currently post the governor's Budget on
a website and uh as soon as we have a
house bill too so
this would be an important budget
document we put it out there
so I think we're a good representative
Weiler
so would you think it'd be more
appropriate to put it on the on the LBA
website rather than the department of
administrative services
well as this is written it would be good
for administrative services to have it
but we will too
will be on both
all right show a hands the support of
the Wilder Amendment I'll see unanimous
thank you very much
so the second amendment that I bring to
you
is uh 1046
this is a handy tool when we sit in
a fiscal committee as we do every month
and people are coming in looking for
money and we're sitting there wondering
okay where's that going to come from and
usually they come from like the rainy
day fund but before we hit the rainy day
fund
if we know of the lapses that haven't
been spent throughout the budget that
would be an easier place to get the
money that we know it won't be spent
somebody cancel the contract or whatever
happened so money lapsed from a certain
agency it would that was General funds
but lapse to the general fund or
whatever fund we're looking for money
for for requests at fiscal so this is
this is a way to get those lapses done a
little more quickly and when we meet
every month on fiscal we could say oh
okay we've got money here to cover what
your request is without trying to go in
in the in the red or or hit the rainy
day fund so it would seem like a better
source of the funds that the requests
for fiscal and they're not usually huge
funds but
you know beer might be a few hundred
thousand here or there so I thought this
might be a good way have that money
available
so that's the reason for this that if we
know what the lapses have been on fiscal
then we can have a pretty good idea what
we can hand out thank you represent
McGuire thank you does the department
ever
think they're going to lapse in one
fiscal year and then in the next one
oops they have some extra need and they
take back from their first year lap sort
of and and you could have already spent
it this way is that going to be a
problem the only one we ever have seemed
to have trouble on making the lapses and
roughly we give you money we expect like
a three or four it's three or four
percent laps and okay so you know you're
not going to spend 98 you're not going
to spend 100 of it and you keep that in
mind as you spend through the year and
obviously when when you see some big
changes you say oh good that's that's
money I won't have to worry about the
the HHS has always been the problem of
course it's such a huge agency so many
different pages as you'll see in this
budget that um Sometimes they come to us
and say we're not going to make our laps
so they're going to spend roughly 104 of
what we think that we're going to spend
so
that would be one that that would be
problematic and probably won't even make
these reports
but if the other the other 49 of the
state agents spending
then that should be enough to cover the
the things that we usually get at fiscal
seeing no more questions on the second
Wilder Amendment
I'll just put your hands up if you're
okay with it we're good
thanks thank you very much sorry I
wasn't with you earlier today I hear you
we're doing some very good work I saw
that wall covered up with things
yeah it was work
and he had a huge audience here too
disciples too yeah
Jackson's value is recycling very good
all right I'm on break from division
representative McGuire often draws a
crowd we face
yeah
he seems to be super energized then
we're going to need that energy to get
through this budget thank you
all right
well thank you representative Weiler
so it looks like if I'm not mistaken Mr
Hoffman Melissa all these others that
haven't been shaded are just adding the
dollar amounts in which we discussed
when we made those adjustments is that
correct
yes we just didn't record agreement on
the complete budget for those agencies
because there was still work being done
on the additional requests in the house
bill two items
so for example a child advocate
some of the additional requests were
funded but we didn't get a nod on the
budget as amended
all right so we'll
do the nod on
let's see
Treasury Department we just discussed
that Revenue administration department
um
oh 84 are we okay with that the judicial
Council
below that
zero seven
we talked about Justice that's 2-0 and
then human rights seven six
Corrections
Liquor Commission those additional
requests approved
business and economic affairs
and environmental services
so everybody okay show of hands with
allowing the
the only the only thing we showed is
open was business and economic Affairs
we had the Small Business Development
Center on hold oh we had that on hold
okay
we uh do we I mean I had suggested even
just another 50 for them but I wasn't
sure how that was received
instead of 390. I think they'd take
anything
further comments you suggesting a firm
number
yeah so it would be in well I said I
think they are they have 390 what if we
made it 450.
yeah sbdc
Small Business Development
yes represents Sweeney so I I remember
this fund request to hire in a
advisor for biotech
is that what
this group right no they they weren't
what
we had a letter though Melissa Mr
Hoffman can you help us out please
this is an organization that helps
um small businesses get started they've
had an appropriation for in the past two
budgets I think the request is to bring
them up to five hundred thousand dollars
and they're at 390 in the budget right
now right and and they were here and
then I asked Taylor
commissioner Caswell about it and he
supported the increase he felt that they
did really good work they had requested
500 in the and the governor put in 390.
so
representative Sweeney so I found the
letter
so should the legislature increase
sbdc's annual state funding allocation
in fiscal year 24 and 25 to 500 000 sbdc
will hire a full-time business advisor
to support the growing Biotech Industry
in the greater Manchester region
uh Army and UNH Manchester set aside 50
000 a year for four years for SPD so
that's where I pulled my assumption
that's right and then didn't you to ask
them whether it would be limited to
Manchester and they said no I did they
said it would be a Statewide scope so my
only hesitance on it is biotech is such
a profitable business so they may not
need that I I just feel the industry
itself can find the funds as opposed to
pulling general fund dollars for that
position that's my view on it
representative McGuire yeah and he
obviously didn't convince the governor
who's probably a soft touch on this kind
of thing so I just I I had committed to
raise it again so I did thank you
all right so there's your answer Melissa
and Mike
on that uh
there's one there's one other item
representative evil it wants a
indulgeable what we did discuss it a
little bit yeah we did so
just um if you go back to hb2 section
um 84 it's on page three of this thingy
I just wanted to ask you guys where it
says regarding the Christa McAuliffe
Memorial it says delete sections
I don't think we planned on just
pitching the memorial
we were talking about the funding
so if you look at section 83 right above
where you're you're talking about yeah
um that was the Christa McAuliffe
Memorial that was creating the
commission to discuss the statute
um the next section was the
appropriation would you agree on the
next section is the effective dates of
both of those it was just into one line
so we said Paul the effective date
because if it's not an effective date
for that section it just goes naturally
to June 30th correct correct the only
reason needed that effective date and
the only reason for June 30th was
because there was an FY 23 appropriation
so now the language in the first section
will remain with the July 1st effective
date
zero zero so
so that was one of the things I just
wanted to talk to the committee about
maybe we could put a hundred thousand in
it or just something to get them going
um there's a great deal of feeling among
people that uh several of us have been
hearing from that we really would like
to just she I mean obviously Krista
McAuliffe is an iconic person and to get
the process going the governor certainly
was convinced that we should put 500 in
maybe we could at least put in a hundred
or or whatever the division
thanks I I didn't want to let it go
unremarked based on the input that I've
gotten since our decision representative
I'll agree with that 100
it's been moved by representative Evil
seconded by representative McGuire to
add back a hundred thousand dollars to
that line
discussion
uh okay we'll take we'll just have a
show of hands everybody okay with that a
hundred thousand dollars
represent Cabral
[Laughter]
all right
six to one okay representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman representative
McGuire made a comment and did uh
cause my brain gear to start moving uh
do we need a formal Amendment for the
housing portion of hb2 I think we we
moved it right I changed the policy and
I think we need the
um
that's the one for Grant so we have sent
that out to OLS it's the one removing
the loans in the Housing Development
keeping the grants and the
municipalities and then 15 and 15. yes
we're moving 15 15. so we do have an
amendment out to OLS for that okay
perfect
so do we have anything else uh Melissa
that Mike
oh we have
wow so
we're just going to recess this our work
session until a time probably Friday
just in case Friday at 9 30 but we
probably won't have to get together but
so
uh Janet so we're going to recess this
until Friday at 9 30 in case something
else comes up so yep thank you
I have fiscal at 10.
is it a one Friday
we should look yeah I better look
yes I have facilities
we have until Friday
yeah so actually
I have facilities I forget I think at
nine on Friday morning and they're gonna
go over the legislative budget then
are you on that Joe
oh
so it's possible at 9 30 somebody will
be here and recess the hearing until
yeah such in touch
24.
yeah you're right 1pm so we'll do it at
ten ten minutes
yeah so we'll
be here at recess until 10 a.m on Friday
yeah again thank you all yes
representative McGuire yes I I want to
say something I an organization day I
went to representative walner and
representative Smith and I said is it
possible that we can get a bipartisan
budget because
um clearly you know we need one to pass
and
um they both said yes and that that in
the past we had had bipartisan budgets
and I really enjoyed this experience it
was my fourth time uh on the on finance
but the first time in division one and I
thought we really worked well together
and I think we you know gave into give
and take and um I hope we do have a
bipartisan budget that at least some at
least you know 190 or whatever from both
sides can can support thank you
uh thanks representative McGuires I've
said this before it was it's been a real
pleasure working with everyone I get to
know Chuck a little better we haven't
really crossed paths much outside of
here and uh representative cambrell's I
was worried I wouldn't be able to
pronounce your name I had to practice
for a few days
and I certainly recognize you from
Science and Technology a great addition
and Joe all your work and trying to
bring us together I think it's worked
well and
I've always known you to be a very
thorough thinker you know you and I
appreciate and Jerry's been on division
one a couple of terms a real anchor in
getting things done and Karen being our
Public Works expert was a big benefit
having her here and so I can't say thank
you to Dave Hewitt but we still have a
long way to go we've got to present this
or Dean and I will present this to the
for our recommendations to the full
Committee in the next week and then
we'll do it on the floor of the house
but I think
we should have bipartisan support at
least some at least anyway enough we'll
see thank you very much Mr chair I'd
just like to say uh thank you to you and
and representative McGuire for your
leadership getting us through this and
you know keeping us driving and uh as a
rookie here as a fresh a freshman in
this committee uh you welcome me with
open arms and I can't tell you how much
I appreciated that
all right well I guess I should say
something oh you're competing with a
representative McGuire well I just I
just want to say that I was a veteran
for 10 years of Public Works and
highways so I wasn't sure how it would
be here we were very bipartisan over
there we have been bipartisan here I've
enjoyed it I've I say that guardedly
even with one thing I think we've
learned a lot I've really enjoyed
getting to know you guys and um I look
forward to working with you in the
future and thank you very much also for
welcoming me and
letting me use my pen
thanks guys
foreign